Doh,
Doh do.
We are live.
Hello Brian Red Ban.
Hey Joe,
what's going on fellow?
Not much crazy week.
Very crazy week murder
the comedy store.
Ugh,
that's,
that wasn't saying I was supposed to go down there that night to me.
I decided the day of,
I had too much shit to do that day and in the morning and I said no,
and I don't need to do a set tonight.
I was going to in Wam do the stand up on the spot show which was on before the
roast battle show and I guess where is the show going on in the main room?
Um,
it was one of those air quotes.
Urban air quote.
Yeah.
They scratch records and they have more melanin and some shit went down and I'm
not that it matters.
It was a box show.
Obviously it could have been a white show.
It was,
I don't believe it was anybody in the show.
I think it was just people in the audience and there was a guy on a patio and
uh,
obviously I have like 15 tanned information,
but uh,
there was story is that this guy just walked right up to this guy and just shot
him a bunch of times.
Yeah.
It's weird how,
uh,
I sent you that China did one of those reenactments of it where it's just
commercials rather cdis and it's really ridiculous how they show it.
And so I've been showing it around cause there's a lot of us are always there
Tuesday nights and rose,
the bartender was standing right there.
She,
you know,
she helped afterwards.
Why?
By putting a,
you know,
towels and stuff on the guy.
A lot of people at Francisco Ramos,
which was standing right next to Matt Edgar,
a lot of our friends were hanging out on the patio because roast battle was
going on and it's so,
you know,
crowded for roast battle that a lot of us just sit in the front patio and watch
the Chinese.
It's a first of all note how everyone's white at Daca.
Yeah.
So was it from there?
While it does like the comedy store,
is that where it happened from?
You know,
they're saying that what rose is saying that this is not the side that came on.
It was more right in the middle,
you know,
the insurance.
Uh,
and was he that far away?
They're also saying he ran across the street,
which is another thing a lot of people say that he got into a car and the car
went down the street.
Other people were saying he didn't get in the car.
And it's interesting because there are so many people there,
but yet they haven't released anything about the,
the,
the shooter except that he had a hoodie on,
not like color of Hoodie Height,
nothing,
which was odd,
you know.
Um,
but it happened so fast.
They say,
I don't know how those things usually work.
I don't know if they give up all the information like about the suspect.
The problem is if you,
if you tell people what it was like,
here's,
here's a,
this is a really weird thing that happens when people see stuff,
the people see things,
and then the recollection of what they actually saw.
Oftentimes it's way off.
Like they've done these experiments with people where they've,
uh,
put them in stressful situations.
It's like a fake bank robbery.
And then they ask them to what happened and people,
they get it so wrong and they think their head that it's right.
I mean,
I'm sure I've got some memories in my head like that,
that are all fucked up.
And I'm sure you have some in your head.
I just think,
I think what our memory,
we'd love,
we would like to think it's like some stuff written down on paper or a video
that you can watch and review.
But it's not,
it's,
it's fucking very,
very strange,
especially when it comes to something like a murder where someone steps out and
boom,
just shoot somebody.
So if you say,
we're looking for a five foot 10 black male with a red Hoodie,
people going to find that guy.
They're gonna see it,
they're gonna think it thinking that.
But if you say we're looking for a five foot 11 thin white male with a British
accent,
then they'll say,
I saw that guy.
I know it was him.
There's going to be a certain amount of people that will tell you,
even though they saw a black guy in their head,
they'll see that five foot tall 11 English guy and the go,
yes was,
I did think he was English like in their head,
especially with like trauma and the fear of the instance,
they are notoriously unreliable.
That's why like when scientists talk about anecdotal evidence and evidence of
people's experiences,
when you're trying to talk about like paranormal shit especially,
so people say,
dude,
you can't tell me what I saw.
I know what I saw.
Do your really,
do you really know what you saw?
Because I don't know what I saw a lot of times,
like if you looked at my memory just from like yesterday,
it's a blur of some snapshots,
you know?
And I had a great day.
I wasn't drunk hanging out with the family but picked out some pumpkin's w saw
fucking pig race went to this foreign place where they,
you know,
they let you pick out your own pumpkin.
It's fun.
It's a bunch of kids.
It was cute.
We had a good time wetting up corn maze,
you know.
But my,
my memory,
my important thing is like totally sober,
having a great time.
Lots of laughs.
But my memory like,
oh yeah,
then we did that and then we did it.
Oh yeah we did that too.
I had some that eh had a sandwich and these,
these like this idea that,
you know,
we have this infallible memory.
I think when you start putting out information like a,
this is what the guy definitely looked like based on who?
Based on whose head,
who said it looks like that.
The people that saw the shooting.
Hmm.
Okay.
If you don't have a photo,
you,
you better be real careful what you say because these people that saw the
shooting,
man,
boy,
I mean some of them might be good at it,
but we all know somebody who fucking sucks at remembering stories.
You know,
we all,
we all have that one person that is terrible at it,
especially in a time of panic.
I know when I got robbed,
I remember he had a fake beard and in,
but that's about it.
Like I didn't like,
I had some kind of coat,
but I don't remember like I was staring at him.
I should be able to know like,
oh yeah,
he had a purple shirt on.
He had it.
You know,
isn't it funny that fake beards are not allowed?
But
if you are a man and you wear a toupee,
you can go through Tsa with it.
Oh yeah.
They'll leave that stupid fake hair glued deer.
That's so strange.
But if you tried to go through Tsa with a fake mustache,
he'd be like,
what the fuck are you trying to pull?
But if you,
you can go in there with a mop up here.
I wonder how long your fake hair can be before they go.
Listen,
you fuck take that thing off.
What could you go in there with like a giant lion's mane?
Like if you,
if you went in there with some crazy,
if you were to stone called bald and you went in there with a glued on Fabio
wig,
like a full Fabio that goes all the way down to your ass or even crazier.
Like there was a dude that I was um,
I was at the House of Blues in Houston a couple of weeks ago and uh,
it was great.
It was awesome.
Meaning you Edwards and a,
there was a dude has been grown his hair for 14 years.
It works here.
I've got a picture of homeboy,
he said a long ponytail.
Is that going?
No,
no,
no.
He went the dreadlock routes.
It just takes one guy to have like tried to put a bomb in his hair piece too.
We have like a line where everyone has to get there like two pays,
like shoveled off or scraped.
Well there's not enough people that have big hair like that where you would have
to like look into it.
But yeah,
if,
if people,
if there was a lot of people running around with a hair like that,
they would start searching your hair.
I definitely 100% but those radio wave things that they go through,
here's how I'm boy see his hair.
Holy Shit.
Yeah.
It goes all the way down to his ass.
His ass,
excuse me.
Almost down to his knees.
That shit's got to smell.
It probably smells great.
Pockets of nest in there.
All kinds of living are art forms in there.
Ebola spite.
The um,
wasn't going to say,
oh,
but you keep,
if that was fake,
like there's no way you could wear hair that long.
That's fig.
Cause now you weren't like some crazy costume or something.
Like it has to be within the cultural norm and has to be like culturally
acceptable length hair.
You know,
like,
like do you remember when that Guy Phil Spector was on trial for murder?
That really crazy.
Fuck Phil Spector,
who Jamie probably knows who he is more than both of us.
Cause he was,
he had that thing,
the wall of sound that he had kind of created.
He cranked kind of created a new way of um,
uh,
producing music.
Is that correct?
That the best way to describe it.
That's good.
Yeah.
But apparently he loved putting guns in people's faces.
He was just a fucking nut and he showed up for trial.
Look at that one.
Look at that wig like he showed up for trial wherein the different wigs,
right?
Didn't you wear a couple different kinds?
He wore it.
Just that one.
No.
What about that one?
Yeah.
So he's got two different wigs.
At least.
What ended up happening to him?
Is he in jail?
Oh yeah.
He's in jail.
He might be dead.
He might be dead now.
Look how,
yeah,
look how horrific he looks.
He just looks so creepy.
Is that him there smiling too?
While it looks like a totally different person when he smiles.
That's so odd.
Oof.
He's a creepy dude.
Yeah.
Well,
so he,
um,
he put a gun in some girl's mouth,
you know,
he was into that kind of shit like,
bitch,
I'll fucking kill you.
And he actually did kill her.
Wow.
And she was like a,
just a young lady.
I think that's her up there.
Atlanta Clarkson.
That's her.
Right.
She was really pretty,
oh shit.
That she had done some ma acting and stuff and she met him.
What's amazing to me was not just that he shot her and that this crazy fuck
with,
but that an ugly dude like that can bang a chick that looks that hot.
Like how did he get her?
Maybe,
maybe she wouldn't have sex with them.
Maybe that's why I shot her in the mouth.
Well,
he's awesome millionaire,
I think at that point,
you know?
Yeah,
no,
that definitely has got to help.
I mean,
it's,
but isn't an amazing that it helps that much.
I mean,
look how scary he is.
Is that Al Pachino?
Did Al Chino play him in a movie Hbo Movie?
I think really?
What was it called?
No Shit.
I didn't know about that either.
There's too many movies.
So it just caught Phil Spector.
Do you know I had a revelation the other day when it came to movies.
Uh,
I went to see the Martian.
It was pretty good.
Interesting.
But it's,
problem is,
the problem with that movie is,
you know,
he's going to live,
he's gonna make it so it's like someone gave you a spoiler alert before you even
got to the movie.
It's like,
oh,
is he going to die on Mars?
Am I paying money to watch two hours of him and he's going to die on Mars?
Get the fuck Outta here.
Everybody knows he's not going to die on Mars.
But the revelation was there's,
there's too many movies and like even really awesome movies,
like sicario supposed to be pretty bad ass because that's the new Benicio Del
Toro movie.
It's supposed to be pretty bad ass,
but we couldn't get a ticket to that one.
Um,
in time,
uh,
we,
we were sold out so we went with the Martian.
Um,
but the point is these movies never stop every week there's new ones and they
don't go away.
Like the old ones don't stop being around like you can go watch them too.
It's like there's too many of them.
Like I was thinking about all the different movies just on iTunes and Netflix
and I was scrolling through them and I started thinking like this is an,
this is a never ending equation.
Like it just keeps getting tacked onto it.
We live in the epicenter of where it's created.
It's all around here and it's,
it's very strange because the body of work just never stops.
Like he used to be when I was a kid.
When a good movie came out,
you would go to see that fucking movie.
Like Star Wars.
I saw star wars 13 times and I was nothing compared to the real geeks.
Like there's,
there was like,
it was a big deal back then to see how many times you could see a movie.
Like you couldn't run a movie long enough to see for someone to see it 13 times
now because there's new ones,
there's new ones come in.
We've got to get this fucking piece of shit out of the theater.
You would never have a movie like star wars.
It played over and over and over and over and over and over again.
And if star wars came out today,
people would shit right in its mouth.
It's,
it's weird.
That is to me,
in my childhood,
one of the greatest movies of all time when I was a kid and that movie came out,
I remember when Obi wan Kenobi was talking to Luke Skywalker and,
uh,
they were in the sand.
I was like,
this is the greatest thing I've ever seen in my life.
This is amazing.
This guy's in space and he's gonna Obi wan Kenobi is going to teach them how to
be a jet.
I,
ah,
this is the greatest wound we have.
Our,
I remember it couldn't have been more perfect.
I remember seeing that movie and thinking,
this movie is fucking perfect.
Now you go watch and you're like,
oh my God,
it's such a clunky Turd.
It's clunky.
The special effects look like shit.
Why is Darth Vader evil?
Does he,
does he just not even a reason why he's evil?
He's just evil.
What does he get when he takes over the world is even get pussy is even going to
get any pussy in space.
He know he's just building some giant star that can blow up planets.
Really?
This is so dumb.
Like it's so dumb.
Oh,
it uses the dark side.
not the dark side.
It's so fucking dumb and it's puppets.
It's like Kermit the frog and the Skywalker in its day.
Like if you judge it in the context of its day,
it's one of the all time classic films.
It's just,
there's so many more now and they're better.
There's some films from back then that still like apocalypse now is a rock
solid.
You try to go watch apocalypse now.
It is rock fucking solid.
Francis Ford Coppola just made a masterpiece.
That's who did that,
right?
It was him,
Yeah.
Some,
it's a masterpiece.
It's a masterpiece.
It's like a flaw was film and it's a film that took,
I think it took like seven years to make and went way,
way over budget.
They started with Laurence Fishburne when he was like 17 years and in that
movie,
I mean that was a crazy fucking movie,
but it's,
it's a,
it's a movie that holds up,
man.
It still holds up.
Ghostbusters.
It doesn't hold up.
He doesn't hold up.
There's a lot that happened watching and going.
Ah,
we were,
we were kids though,
right?
Yeah,
we were younger,
but we were,
it was just looked real back then.
That was like realistic too,
is you know,
those monsters made out of clay.
We're like,
oh my God,
it's a monster man out of clay.
I remember I used to like land of the lost.
Ooh,
the sleaze tax.
There are fun.
So cool.
Look and Ooh,
excited.
Godzilla King Kong movie coming out.
Oh Christ.
Here's why.
That's stupid.
Okay.
Godzilla is 500 feet tall.
King Kong's 50 feet tall.
Did you stop?
Does Japanese people fucked you?
They fucked you with those movies because they violated all the laws.
They didn't give you some reason why King Kong grew to 500.
He grew 450 extra fee.
They didn't say a word about it.
Come on man.
How's he so big?
He was,
he,
he used to be able to climb shit and he would carry the chicken his hand and now
all of a sudden he's as big as Godzilla.
What if it was baby Godzilla versus King Kong?
Like it was just baby Godzilla.
He was small.
Don't make a little bit more sense.
Right?
But he would just stand back and light them on fire.
It's fucking stupid.
Fight will take 30 seconds.
I mean,
to get killed by little tiny airplanes.
He got killed by airplanes.
And if you know anything about like firepower and guns,
the idea that you could kill a gorilla with these little piss ant bullets from
a,
um,
a tiny little stupid cardboard plane.
There's there that you're killing a gorilla that's so fucking big that it can
carry people and climbed to the top of the empire state building.
He can grab planes out of the air and smashed them.
Remember it was doing that,
but yet those little baby bullets are killing them.
Those little baby bolts would just make him furious unless they were like the
hollow points or something like that where they blew up inside of him.
It doesn't matter.
Unless they were cannons,
they would have to be like,
they don't have to be such of a such a high caliber that it would be like boom,
boom.
They would be mad fucking recoil.
It would be me.
Especially back then they figured it.
They have guns now that I have,
they're like a,
Donald's Serone had one that he put a video of it on his Instagram.
It's,
I think they call it integrally suppressed,
so when you fire the gun,
it's a 300 win mag,
which is a big round.
It's a very powerful rifle.
When you fired,
it's like Tunc Tunc like nothing.
You don't feel anything and you don't hear anything.
It's like a very small amount of sound and a very small amount of kick.
Like,
he has a girl on his Instagram picture,
just a regular sized girl shooting it and it's not fucking her up at all,
but it should be like at least a struggle,
you know,
so,
but back then they didn't have any of that shit back then.
It was just like an explosion and the metal tube shooting out a piece of lead.
The idea that you're going to kill this big gorilla with your piss ass guns.
He's going to fuck you up man.
And he's going to bang that white chick.
That's what he's there for.
And it's,
they got smart and you know,
it was just all like hacking and like nuclear war.
Like God's Zelle is using computers now and King Kong.
Nevermind.
Where were you going with that?
You committed to it too.
It made it a drama drama.
Well,
the,
the last God,
Zillow looked like it was going to be bad ass.
I never watched it.
It wasn't good.
It was kind of fun.
Like a,
the Godzilla monster itself was fucking Badass.
Like they did an amazing job with CGI,
but the,
um,
the story was so clunky and this fucking kid who's the hero keeps surviving.
I mean,
he survived the most ridiculous shit.
Like a plane fell off a or a train fell off of a giant bridge into the water and
he gets out of there like over and over and over again.
It wasn't that what happened,
some stupid shit like that over and over and over again.
This fuck survives the most ridiculous,
preposterous disaster scenarios to watch Godzilla kill
this bad guy.
And the spoiler alert,
Godzilla survives spoiler.
But it's just the special effects were pretty wicked.
But the story itself was just clunky.
Did you see a movie called the guest?
I don't think so.
Who's in it?
Uh,
I forget his name.
I was not,
no one really.
Hold on.
I'll tell you right now.
It is,
uh,
add no,
Dan Stevens,
I don't know that is.
Anyways,
it got really good on rotten tomatoes.
I got like 92%.
You know,
like it got really good reviews.
Doug Benson told me to watch it.
It's on Netflix right now.
It starts off like a kid's like,
like kids like summer or you spoiler alert.
No,
not,
it's like,
it starts off this,
uh,
like a kid summer teen movie,
right?
And this guy,
uh,
who just got out of the army comes visits.
This family is one of the biggest road house type version movie.
It starts off horrible,
but then you wake up out of this coma,
you're like,
wait,
what the fuck am I watching?
And then it started like,
I swear to God,
I laughed so hard in this movie,
like a cut,
like a roadhouse accidentally.
But then I go to Doug and I'm like,
dude,
thank you so much.
That was like holy various movie.
And he goes,
oh well you like,
he liked it for real disease.
You know,
Doug Benson quite possibly might be the worst poster boy for wheat alive.
I just did is getting Doug with high.
And he would like ask a question and then I'd be like starting to answer.
And he goes,
oh,
what are you talking about?
Like took completely forgot what it,
well in his defense,
listen to what you just said.
30 seconds go.
Well Godzilla hacking computers guide.
Zillow was like a drama.
Like if they like it made it a drama.
King Kong was hacking Godzilla and made it like a,
what was that picture of view?
But this uh,
this idea that Doug Benson smokes too much pot.
We should explore this cause I know he enjoys the marijuana and I know he's been
a,
an activist and letting people know,
but this type of behavior is perhaps negative to the cause.
He makes me a not so high.
It's so funny.
It's so high all the time and he gets visually high,
which makes it so much more fun when it closes up like razor slits,
he closes up like there's no ice in there.
Where's your eyes,
man?
It's like you don't have any eyes.
Dot.
Merera if he was a pirate or something,
I smoke pot.
We have to get them a cane.
We'd have to get them with those Wa blind canes.
You have to give them a dog.
That Ebola thing about the eyes though,
that really freaked me out.
I should,
how should it bullet has been living in people's eyes.
The guys that had a Bullock spitting,
staying in his eyes,
changing their eye colors from green,
blue and getting,
having blurry vision and then when he gets to checked his eyes are not as
anymore than more
of like a most sure mushier version of this sugar and more.
Sure.
Yeah.
They said that it actually was a,
it was affecting the structure of his eye.
Yeah.
Fuck.
And what's weird is when I went to my eye doctor,
they said my eye structure was fucked and I had scarring in the back for some
reason.
And you don't have a bowl of dude so much skinnier.
You think,
yeah,
they lose a shit load of weight.
Well what if I just have my shit?
The brains out a lazy version of our sleeping or maybe you look a survivor,
you one of those carriers,
like there's some girls that can give you herpes,
but they don't show any signs of herpes.
Right.
This guy right here,
he girls notice.
I blame it all on the girls.
Well,
when did the symptoms is blurry vision.
He started tripping out and stuff.
What I've been trying to deal with myself,
uh,
I don't think you,
you,
you have to be,
you have to consider a couple things when you're talking about your eyes.
You definitely don't have to think about Ebola,
but you do have to think about taking care of your health.
You don't take care of your health.
And I've told you before,
it freaks me out.
Well,
I've cut out things like boner pills recently and,
well,
you definitely should cut out those.
Look,
they have Viagra and Cialis and stuff like that.
And it's like scientifically proven.
You,
you can adjust your dosage.
You don't know what you're taking when you take those things.
And a lot of times you aren't taking Cialis.
You are taking Viagra.
What,
what's weird is Lamar Odom who just recently,
you know,
I went to the hospital for a,
they found him at the bunny ranch.
She had sits like supposedly cocaine around and uh,
these,
these boner pills,
he's gas station,
boner pills.
Uh,
what's so weird about the whole thing,
about two days before that happened,
I found out they fda.gov Gov on their front page,
if you go to it right now,
has a whole thing about these boner pills.
And they also have links to every single like boner pill that you can buy.
Like I took all my wrap,
I keep my rappers like,
cause they come in and he's like,
cardboard saved them like baseball cards.
They're cool because they all have really good artwork and you know,
so they need good artwork.
It's just like David chose were the Mona Lisa on those things,
man.
So I looked at my favorite one.
My favorite one has viagara in it,
the Mexican version of Viagra in it.
But a lot of them also have steroids.
And um,
and if you can go through this,
like this is the hidden agreement.
Like a lot of them are steroids,
a generic names for Viagra.
Well,
you know,
that was Anderson Silva's excuse when he tested positive for steroids.
That makes totally sense.
He took a Chinese Viagra and,
but what they think is,
this is actually one way,
it could be what,
what had happened,
what he said,
could it be true that he might've gotten some sort of a,
it might've called it Viagara,
but it might've been like some super strong boner pill that also has steroids in
it.
But the other,
what they were thinking is that with a company that makes this Viagra or Cialis
or whatever,
it was also make steroids and they just didn't clean their batch and some of it
got contaminated,
which does happen.
We've actually,
um,
we've,
we've run tests on different supplements that we have like,
um,
a Alpha brain.
And during the early days
when we first started doing it,
we would notice that there would be a certain inconsistency in,
um,
in like the amount of something.
It was just like minor,
but enough to we'll guy.
Hmm.
And then occasionally we would find something,
um,
in a supplement.
Like we never found it in,
in a alpha brain or true mood or something like that.
But I know they've found it in like,
well you get like a B 12 supplement and it has vitamin A in it.
For some reason it never was like,
well how'd that get in there?
Or You have,
cause you're getting your stuff from like bulk.
You're getting it from a lot of people are getting with if they're getting like
Tribulus I know used to buy that stuff.
Right.
Well if you're getting vitamins you,
you're getting them from these bulk supplies.
Like my friend Larry used to run that vitamin company and when you get stuff
from bulk suppliers,
like a lot of times they,
they're mixing their stuff in these vats and they just don't clean them.
They do a shitty job of cleaning them.
Most of the time you're okay.
But if,
if someone fucks up and doesn't do their job or you,
you deal with some low level company that doesn't take care of their shit,
you definitely,
definitely,
definitely can get steroids and things along those lines inside like protein
powders and insides,
muscle supplements.
They shouldn't be there.
But then there's also some of them,
they just put steroids in there.
You know why?
Because steroids work so and you can get cheap Chinese steroids and you just
throw them in your boner pills and you'll let want to fuck like a gorilla.
Cause cause you're juiced up man,
you actually on steroids and it will fuck with your mood.
We had that Jeff Novitsky Guy,
he's the guy who works for the u s antidoping agency and he's the guy busted
Lance Armstrong and now he works for the UFC and he's,
you know,
doing all these crazy random drug test.
He told us about all the different substances that the Olympic Committee and the
FDA finds out test positive for steroids.
And we're like well how many are there?
So we go to the fucking website,
there's a website where it lists each one of them.
We didn't even get through the Aes,
we were in the A's and there was hundreds of them that are just steroids.
So when you're going into the the,
you know,
local vitamin Shoppe and you're seeing,
muscle build 5,000 some fucking guys shred it on it.
A lot of those are steroids,
especially more so back in the day than today because they're a little bit
better at busting people and there's a little bit less people that are willing
to take the chance of getting arrested or of getting sued or whatever.
But there's a lot of that shit that's just,
there's so much monkey business involved and like those kind of like muscle
building things
at whether it's really dangerous because all the ones I had were on the fda.gov
and I,
and so then I started taking each one of the boner pills and showing like
looking at every single ingredient that was in it.
A lot of them were roots and like mixing certain things with other things.
Have net has never been tested.
And uh,
like if you have low blood pressure,
you could die off these boner pills just from,
of you have a heart if you're on a heart medication.
Yes.
Like old dudes that have um,
uh,
heart attacks.
They have to take nitrates like nitroglycerine and stuff like that.
If you,
if you take that like you ever seen those in those movies,
the guy would almost be about to take a hard time.
Then he popped those little pills and chew them up.
He's got to get to my heart pills.
You remember that?
Oh yeah.
It was always in those movies.
Remember?
That's real.
Yeah.
There are um,
certain,
uh,
I think it's Nitroglycerin,
but certain things that you take that if you are on those and then you take
Viagra,
it can be super fucking dangerous for you.
So these people are just taking them thinking that what's on that label is
what's actually in it.
A lot of times that's not the case.
A lot of times.
Just a bunch of extra shit in there.
Uh,
the one that I recently have been taking,
it's had,
I ended up having a fire in it,
but they had a new formula version,
which the FDA hasn't tried yet.
But the new form live version works really good,
like way better than the old stuff that,
but I think that has whatever's in,
it's making me trip.
Yeah,
it's probably super bad for you.
It's probably some crazy stimulants.
And who,
who knows,
man,
you got to buy stuff from reputable sources like this.
That's one thing that I disagree with people when they want to have total
deregulation of drugs and and things like,
man,
you gotta be careful of people that are just going to sell you some shit and
tell you it's one thing.
But it's actually something else.
Like there should be some form of regulation when it comes to things like,
Eh,
you know,
anything that's got something in it that could be dangerous where it's like a
stimulant or metals rip fuel type things.
It turned out to kill a bunch of people.
Like you should.
We should,
there should be some accountability and there also should be someone checking on
that stuff.
Like you kind of need someone checking to make sure that you're not gonna like
inadvertently give someone who thinks they're just going to get some herbal,
you know,
testosterone booster,
you're actually going to give him steroids and Viagara,
you know,
she'd be GNC.
Why didn't you say,
I mean,
I bought rip fuel when I was in high school.
We used to all get on that shit.
Nice school people died from that stuff.
Yeah,
definitely.
That's why a federal like you can't get that shit anymore.
People used to just buy a federal used to be able to buy that.
That's uh,
it's fucking stimulant and the hardcore one too.
And it just jacks your heart rate up man.
Like my good buddy used to drink that red line stuff everyday in the gym five
times a week and he's drinking red bull four times a day anyway.
But he's lucky.
He's lucky he's alive.
Okay.
I,
uh,
I took rip fuel once before Jujitsu and I literally thought I was going to have
a heart attack.
It didn't make any sense why my heart was beating so fast.
I was like,
I know I was working out and I know it was,
you know,
exerting myself,
but I was like,
but this is just some next level shit.
Like I have to stop.
Like I can't do it.
Like,
I literally couldn't work out after a certain and I was like,
my heart's beating too fast.
It was weird.
It's like your heart's beating too fast,
but you're not that tired.
It's like,
it's just,
your body's just weird and out on you.
It's just like,
what's all this extra shit
and used to be able to get it everywhere.
Yeah.
And it's a lot of that stuff,
man.
Lot of that stuff.
And how they even like,
that's what you said from my experience of being involved with on it and the
creation of Alpha brain.
And when you find,
you know,
you find out your suppliers aren't doing the right thing,
you find out that like you got to make sure that people are like,
you have to test things and double things every step of the way.
And when you're running a company like GNC,
Jesus Christ,
how many products they have on their shelves,
she live aisles and aisles and the hundreds of fucking things from hundreds of
different companies.
And all of them are broadening weight loss and it's mental clarity and fitness,
uh,
it enhancement and,
and you know,
muscle gains in strength gains and size.
You're going to put on weight and like,
Oh boy,
he sure is all this stuff legit.
They don't know.
They don't give a fuck.
They just go,
go,
what do you got?
What do you gotta you got Dick Pills to bring them in here,
bitch.
You know,
and if you bought,
if you went to a store and you got some um,
some testosterone booster,
you know,
it says,
boost testosterone make you feel a lot,
but it really,
it's really Viagara and I'll send your dick is hard all the time.
He'd be like,
dude,
I'm so full of testosterone.
My Dick is hard all the time.
And it would psychologically make you feel like,
yeah,
I'm on some of this testosterone booster.
It's amazing.
You would just go start buying it.
Like for guys,
you give a guy something that makes his dick hard and they're going to think
that they found the fucking thing.
They found the fountain of Youth.
It found it.
They found that they found the holy grail
just makes it thicker and longer.
It's not even hard.
Right.
What the news,
these kinds or like a swelling of the Dick Martin.
What kinds?
Like these generic kinds with all this extra stuff and they can know what you're
taking.
Will you take one if I give,
you know,
I would have to have a scientist go over that shit with a fine tooth comb.
Who knows what's in those things,
man,
don't you don't even know who's making them.
I know fucking spray paint artwork and you like look at the artwork.
I'm definitely putting this in my body.
I hope it doesn't do any permanent damage.
Gee,
why is my eyesight going off fucking wanky?
You're seeing things wiggle in front of your eyes,
eh?
Also,
you know that's a symptom of diabetes.
Yeah.
I don't have diabetes.
Did you go to the doctor?
All right.
Well,
I mean my last checkup was,
I was fine.
How many years ago was that?
Year and a half.
Did you have those symptoms a year and a half ago now?
Well,
right.
I've also wasn't taking boner pills that have crazy shit at him.
Well,
that's true.
You know I would eliminate possibilities.
Oh yeah.
That's what I'm doing right now.
I'm not doing that anymore.
He's got to stop drinking every night and you got to stop smoking.
Stop doing that.
I've been drinking like every other night.
Maybe
that's better.
That's better than every night.
Secret to not drinking.
What about the smoking?
Don't go to the comedy store.
How much do you smoke a pack a day?
You got,
you did so well,
and then you just fold it up again.
Yeah.
Oh,
that's another thing.
The reason why I originally went to the FDA,
I just remembered it,
is because my favorite cigarette,
which is a new cigarette,
got recalled from the FDA because they said that they were not tested like they
were using all this fucking imagine how bad your cigarettes have to be for the
FDA to go.
You know what?
These cigarettes are fucked up.
Yeah.
Those other ones that are killing people at a rate of 500,000 premature deaths
per year in this country alone,
but they're like this,
this one's too fucked up.
Came a whites and camel crush there.
They were not allowed to be sold because they never would have been tested and
they were using all different new filters and things that broken made meant
inside the cigarette.
Maybe it's just people that don't like white people.
That's one thing.
If you're going to have camels,
those are white people,
cigarettes,
Kools and black people.
Cigarettes.
Like if you,
uh,
upper white lights is a white woman,
you either get cool cools or either like secretaries who are super stressed out
or single moms.
They'll smoke Kools occasionally and they have to,
they're tanned.
Then go to tanning booths or black guys.
I'm a cigarette expert.
Yo Newport's who,
who smokes?
Newports I don't know.
Black people and people who like black people,
right?
People hang out with black people.
They swung.
The worst is when you meet a white person that smokes menthols.
You're like,
what happened to you man and filtered.
That's all white guys who were trappers.
They're all like fishermen and trappers and shit and they fucking,
they have hides,
tanning hides on the side of their house,
you know,
like tacked down to hide and stretched down.
It was Alaska shows.
Those are the guys who smoke camels on filtered.
The only reason I smoke this is James Dean used to smoke lucky cigarettes and I
was like,
I'm,
I'd be like,
James Dean could move lucky unfiltered.
You know else James Deane smoked tolls.
He smoked polls too,
so he probably like just like things in his mouth.
I mean,
nothing wrong with that,
but maybe you shouldn't do what he does.
What do you think about playboy man?
Like taking all the nudity out.
He was very upset.
Bailey j are the funniest tweet about it.
Yeah.
She goes,
she goes,
there's girls online that have fist up.
They're assholes.
You weren't reading playboy.
Stop it.
Yeah,
it's true.
It's totally true.
It's just fucking true.
Larry Flynt,
it was on like CNN the other day and he said it perfect.
Like,
like,
like you're taking your bread and butter away.
Why would the fuck he's at Hugh Hefner?
It's just a horrible businessman.
He's like,
he,
he's the magazine's fine.
You know,
don't touch it.
Well he's old.
I don't think he's necessarily running things anymore.
And I think this,
the fact
that we're talking about it means it was a good idea cause we're talking about
it.
No one talked about playboy,
like playboy.
Nobody gave a fuck.
They have to literally have to do something like this in order to get people to
talk about it.
It might be a good idea.
Honestly.
I mean I'm,
I'm the shittiest businessman of all time cause I don't,
I literally don't think about business ever at all.
I just do shit that I like to do and try to like work as hard as I can and try
to keep going,
find things that I'm interested in and keep going.
I never sit down and go,
what's the best business model?
What I need to do for my brand.
I need to expand.
What I need to do is I need to create some sort of a publicity stunt.
But if I was going to engineer a publicity stunt,
that's the best one.
He take either that or you show calming.
He just show a lot of hair polling and nothing in people's faces.
He show like hardcore choking and Mascara and snot coming out of girl's nose and
balls hitting Chin's.
You're either going to go one way or the other.
Either you're going to go the route of the Internet and the Internet is going to
out Internet.
Yeah.
Every fucking time.
Or you're going to decide,
you know what,
we're a gentleman's magazine now.
You can get plenty of porn.
You don't need us for that.
You're not buying this in,
uh,
airport.
Fucking one.
Those little s with the plastic.
You're not going to go jerk off in your hotel room with us.
You just not does this.
You have a laptop,
stop it.
Right.
But they can offer like good articles,
right?
Like there's people that have written for playboy,
they were like really good writers.
There's some really good stories that had been written for playboy,
but it was always sort of obscured by the fact that really what you were doing
was buying it for chicks.
It was,
that was the inside joke is like,
oh,
I read it for the articles.
That was the inside joke.
Like people would laugh about how nobody really read it for the articles.
But if you go and like you ever see like Frank Sinatra f interview,
the,
these,
those interviews and playboy,
these do,
if you're seeing those,
I actually have never read one single article in the interviews are classic.
You know,
I,
I did an interview with playboy a long time ago and that's when I got into it
with Denis leary.
Uh,
yeah,
that was from one of those playboy interviews.
This,
they've always had playboys,
always had like really good interviews.
They vote.
They had,
like I said,
I used to have this coffee table book of all the great interviews over the years
in playboy,
but the,
the whole feel of playboy,
Timmy was always style.
Like it was artistic.
You know,
Hugh Hefner was an artist that,
you know,
made women look beautiful and like you,
you wanted to see whatever.
Uh,
who else is Sigourney weaver naked?
But you wanted to see waiver and then we got naked and shit.
You wanted to see her get naked.
Pamela Anderson Class.
He corny weaver window.
Yeah,
I know what you're saying.
So famous.
You wanted to see a class like that's where Kardashians should have had her butt
shots instead of that other thing.
It was too late though.
By the time she came along.
It was a ghost town.
Right.
But playboy,
yeah.
No one's talking about playboy because no one's talking about magazines at all.
Anything about magazines?
Playboy problem I think is like what Larry Flynn was saying,
that their business is all fucked up.
Playboys.
I believe it's subscription based to listen to playboy radio.
You have to pay $7 a month.
You know,
it's like a stew.
Yeah.
It's not like you can just turn on all playboy radio.
You know,
it's,
wait a minute,
is it on serious?
It used to be on serious,
but I think Sirius was like,
Eh,
we don't care about this anymore.
Bad on the,
sure.
Yeah.
I used to be 10 bucks a month though,
or something like that on serious anymore.
I don't think it is
valuable.
The,
the model is definitely dying.
The magazine model,
um,
well it was an internet radio station and originally launched on Xm Sirius
on a,
okay,
here we go.
On March 9th,
2013,
Kevin Kline and Andrea,
they announced that playboy morning showed that the playboy will no longer be
featured on sm Eric,
Sirius Xm.
Hmm.
Uh,
you can only go to playboy radio and they want you to pay for it.
Playboy radio.com.
Yeah.
See that's a big mistake.
That's a big mistake to get people to pay for it because,
well,
why would they do that?
When you can get the Ted Radio Hour,
you can get getting Doug with high,
you get killed,
Tony.
You can get the Church of what's happening now.
You can get,
you can get fucking,
there's so many podcasts that are amazing and they're free for playboy to come
along and say,
hey,
we want $10 a month or $7 a month or whatever it is.
It's $7 a month.
Too much or $10 a month too much.
It's just,
you can't do it.
You can't,
it's a shitty model.
That's you're,
you're,
you're operating on this idea that likes subscription based stuff still exists.
And it really doesn't,
unless it's something like Netflix,
just think about how arrogant you would have to be to want $7 a month for your
fucking podcast,
your radio show,
when you can get Netflix for nine bucks a month.
Did they raised it right?
They made it nine now I think Netflix did.
It's still a great deal.
Amazing deal.
Just stop and think about that.
Think about how many fucking standup comedy specials I believe.
Oh,
I can't even say that.
I'm not supposed to,
but um,
look,
I think,
just think bill burrs specials.
Thompson Sigora just shot his second special,
you know,
fuck I,
I did one on Netflix in 2005.
So it's like,
you think about all,
it's 10 bucks an hour,
is that what you're showing me?
Playboy radio
radio is $4 and 17 cents a month.
If you do it 12 months a description.
If you do it for one month,
it's what?
17% about $5 a month.
Okay,
so five bucks a month.
It's still more reasonable with still ridiculous.
No one's paying that bad business model.
It's terrible business model.
It's like,
you know,
they're talking about doing that with Howard Stern.
They were talking about doing that with something like Spotify and make it the
way they were talking was so gross.
And then I said they,
I mean these business analysts who were quoting people who supposedly work for
this show,
it could be all bullshit.
It could be all rumors,
but the way they were saying it was like they were banking on it.
You know,
because at the end of the day,
if there's anybody that can get people to pay for war,
uh,
some sort of a podcast,
it's him.
I mean,
he's got Howard Stern's got the most loyal listeners.
It's been around the longest time.
There's people that for him,
for them,
he's a part of their daily commute and has been for decades.
Right?
But they were talking about like doing it where it's like $7 a month for his
show.
And they were like,
we could get 10 million listeners,
so he'd be getting $70 million a month.
I'm like,
bitch,
are you out of your fucking mind?
You really think you're going to get 10 million people?
They're going to pay $7 a month for a podcast.
10 million.
Good luck.
Good fuck.
That's crazy talk.
But listen to someone say something like that.
I was like,
Ooh,
look how they think.
They just looking at it like,
Ooh,
this is a business.
Not like,
let's just keep doing the most kick ass radio show in the history of the world.
Let's keep having these amazing guests.
Isn't it crazy?
Howard's been on the air for decades and he's got all this stuff banked up.
You can listen to Howard 100 and year classic interviews from back and it's
amazing.
Let's keep this better and better.
Nope,
that's not how they think.
They think,
how do we make money off of them?
How do we take this guy and how do we turn this into 10 million subscribers
paying $70 a month and then they're all thinking if I just get a piece of that,
if I get a piece of that,
that they're looking at their house in the Hamptons and then they thinking about
their Porsche,
there'll be drive in.
Ah Right.
And then you've got all these people around you that are like grabbing and
pulling and tugging.
That's what it's like.
If you work for some big giant ass corporation that feeds off of having a bunch
of different shows on its network.
Like if you work for some corporation,
like a,
like a Sirius XM or playboy or anything like that,
like they need to keep that fucking thing alive.
Like we need money coming in.
We cannot just operate on the ideas.
We need money coming in.
Well,
I think we can get playboy radio and a half people will pay about $7 a month.
Let's do it.
Seven Mag.
That money,
how much?
How many people do you think we're going to make?
I think about a million a month.
1 million a month.
5 million a month.
We're out of the whole,
how the whole in six months.
And people start thinking like that and then,
you know,
but what the fuck do I know?
Oh Shit.
Larry Flynt also said,
you know,
like look,
he playboy probably has 43 writers.
You know,
he,
they,
they probably have a shitload of writers.
He's like,
I have seven.
he's like,
he's like very Flint said that.
Yeah.
And it makes sense.
He's like Larry flynts.
Like I make a profit every month.
They don't,
you know,
I mean,
and he's got a hardcore shit on his,
you know,
his,
his magazines.
Hardcores fuck.
And I still bought,
you know,
house.
I still buy a penthouse occasionally.
I actually don't with,
well,
you know,
I swear to God,
I do.
I bought one the other day.
American money.
You don't use bitcoin or anything like that?
Okay.
Oh it's my ex girlfriend on the cover and my bike,
so
yeah,
that's fine.
Yeah.
Um,
I just don't think that they can make it.
It's like you can scrape out as much money as you have.
Keep a skeleton crew,
run,
run those magazines as long as you can while there,
as long as they're profitable.
But be ready to pull that shoot,
be ready to pull that shoot.
Cause now like you can just get shit on your iPad,
that's new.
And then they have these things that are like essentially like Spotify for your
iPad.
Say you can choose from a bunch of different magazines like time and Newsweek
and all these different magazines or you can get them on your iPad,
go through it,
you download it,
you get each page as a full image,
you can stretch it out and move in and it's so much better.
It's so much better.
And once they start doing it like that where you have like these subscriptions,
you know,
it's not going to last they actual print thing.
It's just not going to be around anymore.
Why would you want that print thing?
It's killing paper or its killing trees rather than make that paper.
You could just get the,
the thing downloaded to your phone instantly like that.
It's just ones and Zeros in the air.
You know,
you don't,
it's not gonna make it,
it's just,
it's like the dew tour,
Morse code,
you know,
like,
listen,
I'm telling Ya,
this is the way the talk that I,
the,
it'll never go away.
We'll always need boys code.
Nope.
Nobody knows how to do that anymore.
SOS,
Dat,
DA,
dat.
Remember it was one,
two,
three,
one,
two,
three.
That's o s one two,
three is an s well hasn't been one of those assholes that should,
it has to sit there and try to figure out how many beeps that guy just did.
And you're spacing out and he's beeping at you.
Well,
getting a message from the western front
today,
Eh,
you got to write all that down.
Oh my God.
And then you figure out when is,
when is the word done?
You Fuck,
you didn't put enough of a pause and
you stopped do that in boy scouts SOS.
Did you?
Yeah,
that we had to know how to do it.
We had to know like what the signal was.
One,
two,
three,
one,
two,
three.
But I mean,
how are you going to send it?
What do you send anything with you going to bang on a drum,
radio ball,
ball ball,
ball,
be had an am radio.
You can't transmit ham.
Oh,
ham radio.
That was a big thing,
man.
Still is.
I remember my,
my uncle,
uh,
he would always let me play with it and he'll be like,
yeah,
this guy's in Japan right now.
And you're like,
oh,
hi,
you're in Japan.
What the fuck?
How are we talking?
Right.
It was a cool thing to do,
but to go online,
start a chat with some guy from Japan,
he's just going to show you his dick.
It's just a matter of time,
you know,
there's no like,
friendship thing like that,
like ham radio.
Like back then,
if you were on the radio with some guy,
you know,
and you're like,
uh,
so you,
what time is it in Germany?
Time for me to fuck your mother,
you know,
like that did,
they didn't talk like that.
They didn't talk like Internet people.
They had to actually like speak to each other.
So because that element of you say something,
someone reacts,
there was probably way less trolling.
I'm sure there was like,
and you could get in trouble too.
Like you get your ham radio license taken away from you if you do shitty things.
Right.
I don't even think you're allowed to swear.
I think on a ham radio,
I think there's like restrictions on language
[inaudible] right.
It is regulated.
Right?
I don't know.
I,
let's see.
I know they're going to make you a register your drones now,
so it's gonna be like a car.
You're gonna have to get like a fishing license.
Probably every time you get a drone.
It makes sense.
That was only a matter of time.
I was um,
in,
uh,
Alberta last year or this,
this,
uh,
spring rather.
And this guy had one that was attached to a cell phone and he's flying it around
land and we're watching the image on the cell phone,
you know,
cause it's transmitting.
And I was like,
this is fucking crazy.
This is way too good.
It's way too good.
Way Too good and way too easy.
Cause he's just maneuvering it,
you know,
moving it right.
You can do it with your phone.
You can do it with a remote.
They're the ones that they have now.
There's a lot of them too.
A lot of different models.
They're fucking really good man.
Yeah.
I was thinking about getting one a while ago,
but I think I'll wait it out.
It looks like it would be fun just to do like cool video stuff.
Yeah.
Um,
it is,
it is cool.
I mean,
they're still cool.
I wonder if you get grandfathered in.
It's like if you have like an AK 47 or something,
the grant come and tag it.
Yeah,
I am now.
Uh,
you posted the wrong link off.
So on your Twitter for what?
So you guys are on youtube now streaming instead of a youth.
Oh,
did I post to the use?
Oops.
At Jesus Christ.
I,
it looks great on youtube though.
I'm looking at the picture quality,
right?
How do I find it right now,
Jamie,
if I want to find it so we're not on Ustream.
I just tweeted,
I just tweeted the right still haven't figured out how to do the Ustream at the
same time.
Yeah.
All right,
hold on.
You should be able to just split it that video so it's not,
it doesn't work that way.
The Ham radio stuff,
it's an amateur radio.
There's regulations,
but it depends on how big prior,
how strong your ham radio signal is.
Stuff you can broadcast really strongly.
Then you become like you're a little radio station and then you have
regulations,
but well,
how has that technology work to where people in other countries are listening to
it though?
It's like what kind of radio station is this?
It's better than FM.
Oh,
because it's a little,
it's like a low frequency signal.
Like you can get am radio from all over the place,
right?
Just in your house.
Okay.
You can get radio from radio,
radio goes further,
radio am radio rather it goes further than FM but just doesn't have as high a a
bandwidth.
It's,
I find it amazing when people are still listening to radio.
That's another one.
I thought that would have been gone too.
I still listen to them unfortunately,
but I have friends at work in it and uh,
you know,
they'll,
it's brutal.
You watch the way they work.
It's the same thing because what they're,
right,
besides the plane record part,
what they're doing as a podcast and the plane record part would be fucking
infinitely easier,
infinitely easier if you could do it on a podcast,
if you could just play records on a podcast.
So you don't need a bunch of people working behind the scenes.
You know,
you just,
you just play it.
And if we could just play anything you wanted but you can't really,
you can play it.
But there's like fair use.
You could use something in certain podcasts,
he could use it,
but it's,
it's not a hundred percent clearly defined right now.
But for radio man,
dude,
I talked to a,
I don't want to say their names,
but they're good guys and they're,
they're fun guys.
And I like doing the show.
But um,
one of them was,
uh,
telling me that they just got done with their,
you know,
they have a review where the company comes in,
sits him down,
he goes,
they fucking hate everything we did.
We,
we,
we've been successful for decades.
They've been around forever.
And he goes,
I've never had one of these meetings where they say,
we're doing great.
Never.
Everything is bad.
Everything is not good.
They're always looking to cut staff.
They're always looking to fire people.
It's just like this total negative meeting with these misers and these money
people and these numbers crunchers.
And they're like,
we have to maximize profits.
We have to fit.
We have a strategy to maximize profits when need more commercial.
Two I had more commercials.
So like you'll,
you'll,
you'll do a break and then they'll play like seven minutes of commercials and
then they'll play a song and then you go back to talking again.
You're like,
what is this fucking commercial thing you guys are doing?
Because how many of those can you do in an hour?
If you've got seven and then you've got another time,
well,
you got a half an hour worth of fucking commercials in an hour.
That's crazy.
But it's almost getting to that point with,
with a lot of these radio stations,
they just have so much.
Man,
it's so crazy.
Yeah.
I do it out of pure,
uh,
how easy it is in my car.
You know,
it's just,
she turned the car,
the radio turns on.
You don't have,
you know,
it's kind of like background noise to a point.
Yeah.
That's the only reason I listened to radio.
If it gets to the point where it just automatically turns on my Spotify my card,
then I will,
you know,
serious is so much better in that sense.
Like when I listened to opiod Jimmy,
it's like they're swearing,
they're being honest and swearing.
But even then you have to worry about being fired.
They have to worry about some sort of a public outrage situation when they say
something crazy and people demand their ouster and the,
the heads will roll and the corporation has to bow down.
Well,
you know,
we've,
we've reviewed your file and we've found that this is not the first time you
said anything outrageous.
Anthony Ku,
Mia,
you know,
like,
well that's what he got paid for,
you know,
and they were like,
you're out.
Like he tweeted a bunch of horrible shit where really the,
the great thing would be to do,
to have him come in and justify what he said or explain himself or apologize on
the air or say he was drunk or address it the way he would have dressed it.
And if he did do that,
the fucking ratings would be giant.
Like if they were smart about their,
their business,
the business model,
that's how they would handle it.
Uh,
you,
you've got a builtin ratings boost right there.
Let people talk more about it.
Have people bitch more.
Well,
you should do is tweet some.
You should.
You should have a sock puppet account where you tweet some of the other
outrageous shit that he said over the past five years.
She has just spam it,
spam it out.
It's only going to help.
It's only going to help is going to get more people pissed off.
Yes.
Is it going to get more people to call up?
Your said,
we're gonna cancel serious.
Are you really?
If that's all it takes,
it's all it takes for you to cancel serious.
Fuck off.
Get out of here.
One guy says a few retarded things after he gets drunk and some stripper or a
hooker.
I guess she was a hooker.
Beats him up while he's holding a gun and he doesn't do anything about it like,
come on.
It's a great story.
If that's what's going to get you to quit serious,
think go quit bitch.
They need to be able to say that.
Go quit.
It's a dead model.
Yeah.
That's a just a better version of the dead model.
What they are as like,
they're like a Betamax.
Like the VHS was doomed.
Didn't even know it was doomed.
It was like a little bridge before we can get to digital media and the Beta was
just better.
It's like a better bridge.
Beta Max was way better,
better quality in wars,
but more in a laserdisc even better.
That's even better than DVD.
How about Blueray?
Blue Egg can go fuck itself.
How about that cause you,
it's so amazing.
Look at the quality.
Good.
Good luck with it too.
Why would I get that?
I could stream movies instantly and don't I have to hold your stupid Frisbee?
Sure.
It's done.
It's over.
It's like they got us to that.
They got us to that,
but you can't do that anymore like that.
That model doesn't work anymore.
The model of a like broadcasting shit randomly through the air and you tune it
in she,
oh I got the,
I got it on the dial.
Here it is.
Unless the apocalypse hits,
that's fucking stupid.
You know,
just stop.
Everybody's got their own station.
Remember with Christian Slater had a,
he was a rebel and he broadcasted even though he wasn't supposed to,
he was like turn it up or something like that.
Turned the radio and whatever the fuck that's stupid movie was called pump up
the volume.
That's what he was doing.
What he was doing.
Was it just a really low rent podcast?
You know he was,
I'm going to play real music,
man.
I'm going to say what I think we're going to chase you up.
No,
you're not.
Doesn't change the world podcast.
Don't change the world.
Nothing serious radio being able to sweat it doesn't change the world.
They get mites.
The culture is slowly going to devolve when people are allowed to communicate
with each other.
But the idea that like one guy's going to start a revolution.
I'm going to tell the truth with my radio show.
Listen Buddy,
it's not going to happen.
Your bone structure is too perfect.
You have wonderful hair and the movie you're in sucks.
This is crazy.
I just had a flashback.
Phoned his big ass.
That's a cordless phone.
That's not even a,
um,
that's supposed to be like some satellite phone or some shit like that.
I guess that's supposed to be a cell phone right now.
I don't know.
Yeah,
I guess that's supposed to be like one of those early.
That's like a really cool version of the early cell phone,
high school kids listening to his show.
Yeah,
man,
he was changing the world with those kids.
I bet a lot of people listen to this podcast and uh,
their parents find out about it.
Will you,
you better get that off your phone that Joe Rogan in his marijuana talk,
get it off your phone.
He doesn't even believe in our Lord.
Have you seen,
uh,
not that I don't,
it's not true.
I don't not believe in God.
I don't disbelieve in God.
Just to be clear.
I don't,
I've seen no evidence.
Um,
it'd be seen Manny Pacquiao was Instagram page though.
No,
it's wonderful.
He's got a picture.
It's one of the goofiest pictures.
If you thought Dane Cook's Instagrammers,
a hoot I need to go to go to Manny Pacquiao was Instagram and uh,
see,
see what's going on with this dude.
I have a huge Dane Cook Instagram fetish.
Make his name famous.
Make Jesus name famous.
Wow.
That's,
and it says glorify apparel.
So apparently this is like a real shirt company.
Like if these are the people that like worked for American apparel,
but they got head injuries on the job and they decided to form their own
business with their,
uh,
the money that they were getting from it looks like it.
Got It.
You're,
you're a store lids made it,
it looks really basic.
Looks like it like a moss shirt that you could just get printed out in like 30
minutes.
I was trying to say something,
I couldn't remember what I was going to say.
I was trying to rent that.
Brian American apparel,
whatever.
Head injury,
head injury,
make his name famous.
Look at that.
Oh,
she's just like what?
That's it.
So this is all advertising for the salt.
Jesus.
It's all Jesus people.
Hilarious.
Do you remember on TVs where it used to have,
I just had like a flashback it on our race.
What does that grace upon grace.
That's some lesbian shit.
Great sound great.
You can't do that.
Is that,
what did it say that
that's like having a shirt that says let Jesus come inside you.
You can't even though I know what you're saying,
you can't adopt it with the fuck.
Is that so what were you saying?
I just had a flashback.
Remember on old TVs,
uh,
where you snap a Knob,
but then he had that knob that was in the middle of the knob where you used to
find tune the channels.
We turn it to like channel four and then you had this other night I forgot.
Yeah.
And then there was a UHF and VHF and UHF VHF.
UHF was like the,
the one of them was like the good channels.
Right.
And the other one was like Benny Hill and am radio.
Remember Benny Hill wasn't on the regular TV.
It,
he was on the bullshit
networks.
I forgot all about that though.
I did too.
Yeah,
I do too.
There's a whole,
there's a fucking hilarious harm movie called VHS.
It's like one of those found footage ones where these people,
but the first one is actually pretty fucking cool.
It's one of those movies like God damn it,
if you could keep this up,
if you could keep this up through the whole movie,
it'll be pretty bad ass cause it's a bunch of stories.
And the first one,
spoiler alert,
the first one is about a girl who's a demon and this guy picks his girl up at a
club but she uh,
she turns out to be a demon but it's actually like really well done.
It's kind of,
it's freaky.
They're drunk and they pick her up and she's got like these really weird feet
and then they realize like something's wrong with her.
But she keeps telling them that she loves him,
she loves him.
It's,
it's really good.
But it's only like watch it for 20 minutes,
watch that first one and then throw that fucking thing out the window.
If you have an actual copy,
a physical copy,
Blu Ray,
do you have a blue ray?
That was the other thing is they fucked up with their protocol battles with like
blue ray and I have a bunch of DVDs that are HD DVDs.
You can't watch on anything.
I got a bunch of them.
I got a player if you want.
I don't even,
you could get them all on digital now,
but that's,
see,
that'll be the demise of our knowledge.
That's what's going to happen if,
if you just look,
if you pay attention to what,
when,
when people talk about the possibilities of natural disasters,
like somebody just posted this on the message board the other day that a America
is basically a,
a ticking time bomb.
It's based on some article that someone wrote.
Maybe I'll pull it up real quick,
but uh,
it was based on CVE.
Find the Jamie,
but I think it's in the,
um,
the main form might be in the podcast form,
but the idea was that there's this giant culture of entitled people.
Nobody knows how to do anything for self sustaining.
Nobody knows how to grow their own food.
Nobody knows how to get water.
And we live in these giant population centers.
America is a bomb waiting to explode.
That's it.
And uh,
it makes them really fucking good points.
Like when you,
when you go over it,
it makes some really good points.
It's kind of freaky when you stop and think about how many different things we
rely on that are hanging by a thread that easily could be taken out by a power
grid.
But when you think about our knowledge,
if we do,
if something does happen,
a solar flare or asteroid impact that wipes out,
say 20% of the population stops the power.
And Man,
if,
if all of our shit breaks,
if we lost half the people on earth,
if all of our shit stops working,
computer stop working and we really,
we have to live like the early settlers,
like people are still alive.
The people that are alive today still have the,
the knowledge that they have of live in 30 plus years with,
you know,
the education system and all the technology that's in place today.
These people still out stop.
These people still have those things.
Right?
How,
how much,
how long could you use what we have?
Like how long could you,
well you don't have any power,
how are you gonna be able to generate power?
Some people might be able to,
they might be like a few people with propane generators and still work and some
people might be figuring out how to rig solar or create batteries are used,
the batteries that we have,
but all large scale industrial shit would be stopped.
All construction and manufacturing would cease and desist.
And then all of our knowledge that's on these fucking computers and hard drives
in accessible.
When I was at a and Ohio a couple of years ago for Christmas break,
uh,
maybe for about a week there is a really bad winter storm,
like an ice storm.
Homeless and power was out almost for the large part of the state for almost an
entire whole week.
I thought about that recently.
If that happened here,
even for three days,
this place would almost fall apart.
If there is no power in Los Angeles,
a couple of days,
people are so soft
is fuck here.
First of all,
soft as fuck.
Second of all,
they wouldn't be able to keep food.
The difference between Ohio,
you could put your food out in the garage and it's cold as shit and it would
stay,
stay cold out there.
You,
uh,
in the wintertime out here,
it's still 70 degrees and your food's gonna rot in a day.
In that article,
he said one of the things that is holding on by a thread is the use of mine
altering drugs.
What was that all about?
Oh,
I dunno,
I didn't read the whole thing.
Maybe,
probably if you talk about antidepressants number three,
FDA approved narcotics.
Yeah,
well there's a lot of that re uptake in he,
yeah.
Selective Serotonin reuptake inhibitors,
Ssri,
those are antidepressants.
Pop US population was up 400% of late two thousands over the 1990s.
Many of these drugs are selective serotonin reuptake inhibitors.
These are the type the FDA approved narcotics,
lone gunmen are frequently associated with,
you know,
that's so true that there's a giant percentage of people that wind up shooting
people that are on antidepressants.
But in all fairness,
you know,
there's that,
um,
causation,
causality paradigm like that.
Co,
you know,
causation does not equal causality.
The idea that something happening like just because these two things are
combined together,
it doesn't mean that thing caused that thing.
And there's other factors that you have to prove.
I know people are saying your butcher in that right now.
I know I'm butchering it,
but there's other factors that people have to um,
take into consideration.
One of the big factors is why was the guy on antidepressants in the first place?
Why was the guy on antipsychotic medication in the first place?
If he's on it,
it doesn't mean the medication made him do that.
And it might be mean he's fucking crazy and that's why he's taking shit.
And that's why eventually wound up killing somebody.
But it could be that too.
It could be that.
And it also could be that the SSRS with certain people have an effect that makes
them less likely to feel,
they don't,
they don't freak out about stuff as much and it might make things acceptable to
them,
including violence.
That's,
that's the rub.
That's the scary thing.
Especially if you combine them with other shit like a,
I know Phil Hartman's family,
they won money from Zoloft because Zoloft allegedly I wasn't there.
And when the court happened,
I might,
I have to say allegedly was what I read on the Internet.
I'm pretty sure it's the case though,
because she was,
uh,
doing Zoloft when she shot him.
And that if you take Zoloft and you combine it with recreational drugs,
especially alcohol and cocaine,
especially cocaine is supposed to make you like really nutty when you're,
uh,
doing coke and Ssri is,
it's like very crazy combination.
Yeah.
And if,
you know,
we run out of depression pills or happy pills,
we're going to,
you don't really see that in the movies,
like a half the people are just going crazy and angry and depressed and sad.
You certainly could happen and it,
the road movies,
but you know,
I'm,
I'm worried about all that I'm worried about.
It's not like,
well,
you should know what you need to be worried about is this,
you know,
people love to make that argument.
Well,
you're missing the point.
The point is this.
No,
that's also the point.
There's,
you know,
the world's not a black and white thing.
The world has a lot of points.
There's a lot of areas that we need to look at when it comes to the way human
life is operating today and what we were required to keep it operating at this
level.
We need a lot of shit to think about what we need to run this podcast.
You know,
we were talking about how it's such as small shoestring organization cause it's
just,
you know,
just the three of us in this room and it's reaching all these people,
but you still need like Libson these still need,
you know,
you need like hosts and you need websites and you need,
you need the fiber optic to be laid.
You need the,
the,
the ability to transmit.
You need electricity.
This like a lot of shit that has to be in play.
And then when the power goes out,
all of it stops.
All of it stops.
And the power goes out for a year or two years.
We might as well be living in Mad Max.
And that's a fact.
That's a fucking fact.
When people started getting desperate and their kids don't have any food and
we're trying to figure out how to get gas,
Whoa,
shit is going to get ugly.
You better pack.
If they say,
ladies and gentlemen,
prepare for at least a year of no power,
you got a fucking head north immediately.
I mean fucking immediately.
I don't care what the traffic jams are like,
get out of here.
Get out of here.
Get out of here while you can.
You gotta get the fuck away from this powder keg.
Cause there's a lot of really dumb people here and a lot of poor people and a
lot of crime that,
you know,
what are you gonna do?
They're gonna keep the people in jail and make them starve to death the fuck
they are.
They going to open those doors and Whoa,
having
enough gas to get out of here to live somewhere.
It might even work that might not even work.
Yeah.
It's just this is a terrible place to be if everything stops because there's too
many people and there's too many food requirements and it's too many entitled
dumb dumbs here.
There's too many people that would just fuck it up for everybody.
When you look at things like the riots,
like the riots that happened,
granted,
they were reacting to uh,
uh,
really in their mind a really important moment where Rodney King,
you know,
got beat up by these cops.
They saw one segment of a very long car chase and a prolonged fight with the
cops,
but in the segment they saw these cops are beating that guy with the fucking
club.
The beaten the shit out of him.
They got to quit.
It's,
everybody went nuts,
but they went nuts against people that had nothing to do with it.
They went nuts with people like they,
when they pulled that Reginald gent Denny out of the car and hit him in the head
with a brick on TV,
I'll never forget that.
She's,
that guy's out there right now,
that guy,
there's a guy like that guy,
whether it's that guy or specifically or a guy like him,
he's out there right now waiting for the green light waiting for it.
And there's a lot of them.
There's a lot of them.
And when there's no food man,
no food and no water,
they are,
those are not good combinations and no gasoline to get the food or water to
here.
Whoa.
Good luck.
So all this shit that we have,
you know,
we're,
we're so amazed that our progress,
we're done.
We've done such an amazing job.
Yeah,
definitely.
But it could all go away.
It could go away real quick.
We're putting too much important things on our phones and our electronics.
Like if my phone dies right now and all the electricity goes out,
I don't have numbers to my,
my friends and my family.
I don't have any ways to contact them,
you know,
or personal information and yeah,
I might know 10 numbers.
Right.
I don't even know that.
Really.
And,
and,
and the other thing,
like I had my mom bought me one of those big medical books.
You know,
that's something that you don't even think about.
Like if we have no internet and you get an infection,
you know,
like you should know,
Oh,
poor alcohol and if you don't have alcohol,
pee on it and you know,
or whatever you have to do.
You know,
I'm watching the showtime show,
the Nick Who's seen that showtime does some crazy shit,
man.
They have to,
they're like playboy.
Like nobody gives a fuck about them anymore.
They've got to do something gangster to get noticed.
And uh,
it's,
it's so graphic.
The guys,
first of all,
it's totally unrealistic.
Like the guys suffering from massive cocaine withdrawals.
I just,
whole body's going to convulsions is about to die.
Every vein in his body's collapsed.
So she's got to try to find,
the nurse has to try to find a new vein to shoot cocaine into.
And once she does shoot the vein and he's fine,
now he's up in talking swift and knows his stuff.
He's the best.
This is what we're going to do.
I'll accept your resignation.
You know,
like they like the way they,
you know,
they do these operations,
he's like this mastermind genius.
But five minutes ago he was just spasming and flailing because he couldn't get
his cocaine and all his veins are collapsed.
They shoot it into him and now he's fine.
Can you see what's going on with homeland?
It's kind of hilarious.
And you were watched the artists that worked for homeland,
they wrote shit in Arabic.
How about homeland is a stupid show about our homeland is Islamophobic and a
homeland is,
yeah.
Yeah.
Find that.
It's kind of,
it kind of interesting.
See if you can find the APP,
the actual images.
But what they did is,
you know,
the artists were,
they were supposed to put images in the background.
You know,
they create these environments.
They're supposed to look like Bangladesh or Nepal or wherever the fuck they want
to be.
Right.
And when they have Arabic writing,
they have to bring in an artist to write the Arabic writing.
And what I tell these people are just writing shit cause they know that these
dummies can't read Arabic and they're not checking or double checking and
apparently,
um,
they get shit wrong all the time,
accusing homeland of racism appearing in the latest episode.
Apparently they get shit wrong about like alliances and conflicts.
They make stuff up in order to make the show better.
Wow.
The artist hired add authenticity to a refugee scene shot in Germany.
Also scrawled messages as homeland is a joke and it didn't make us laugh.
That's hilarious.
We will get super sensitive about shows like that.
You know,
you're dealing with,
um,
a war torn world that specifically focuses on the most war torn aspects of the
world.
All the places where the United States has military and they're battling
fundamentalists having these,
these,
you know,
these scenes and they're putting them in these fictional shows and they're
butchering the conflicts and there when you do stuff like that,
man,
like if you're doing a show about game of Thrones,
you can do whatever the fuck you want.
You know the seven kingdoms and you'd have dragons.
You know it's like Natasha is Sheryl calls to make 'em ups.
She,
she doesn't like it cause it's like make,
it's a make them up.
But what I don't like about this kind of a show is like if you're fucking around
with the reality and if you,
if you twist the conflicts and you twist the alliances and you twist the,
the actual historical events in order to make your,
your,
your show like more smooth.
The problem is people who are watching that show,
we're going to believe you.
Like I know you're pretending that it's is like this is just fiction but it's
about real parts of the world.
They should have like the thing at the beginning,
like the following program is yeah.
Cause Yeah I would watch that and think about the beginning.
You can tune in the middle.
You know,
you come in,
you just took a shit.
It's five minutes in.
Yeah,
I'll pay attention to this.
You know,
and you,
you missed all that stuff where they told you this bullshit,
but you know,
they'll make stuff up in order to make their show more interesting or march
dramatic.
What are you doing over there?
Uh,
did you see the new technology where like me and you could be sitting in a room
next to each other in the TV and I can make you talk by using my facial features
and stuff.
You mean you can make the image of me?
Yeah.
Image of you talk.
How,
I mean that's a game changer.
Yeah.
It's pretty freaky.
Do you have that link?
I got this a,
I can just send this to you,
but yeah,
cause that like in the future we could be watching Obama on the TV and it
wouldn't even be him talking,
you know,
it wouldn't be,
I had him making those facial expressions.
You can manipulate the image of someone's facial expression.
Like I could,
I could make you have duck lips and make you raise your eyebrows and,
and it would literally just alter your,
you're the face of your image to match the expressions that I'm making.
Right.
Or if I wanted to have a voice,
you know,
a copy of it.
Like I can like say what can I have another technology where I can have you say
a few words and then have a mimic voice that sounds exactly like you.
So then I,
in the future I can have a,
you look like you are saying something and be completely just a program or two
that are working on your voice and your face.
Well,
what they've done it
past is they've spliced together little snippets of stuff to make it seem like
someone was saying something like they did that with Ronald Reagan,
Ronald Reagan during his administration.
He,
he gave some speech and uh,
somebody,
some bad people.
So we're in the world.
They took his speech and they chopped it up and made it some other broadcast.
Then broadcast it to people all around the world saying,
this is how evil Ronald Reagan is.
But then they showed it on television.
I remember they showed all the different pieces.
I think of that target reenacted.
It's pretty close.
Wow.
It's so weird.
We're looking at a source actor who's on the left and then we're looking at a
guy on the right who's the,
uh,
the CGI.
Like there's this,
there's a guy who is the,
uh,
the guy has got no expression whatsoever.
And then there's a guy who's manipulating him,
who sits above him in the frame.
And as he makes these expressions in the frame,
the guy on the left,
like that guy in the left,
his,
uh,
his face,
even though he's not moving at all,
his face in the image is doing the exact same things that the other guy is.
And what's interesting is like,
it's sort of seems to be accounting for the size and shape of your face too.
Like the size of his lips.
Like you see like the one guy as the bigger lips,
the guy above him look at,
he's got them big Ole Angelina Jolie Lips.
But to do it in the bottom you've got some paper,
lips,
white people lips,
but the paper lips or what's moving.
See,
it's interesting,
right?
Like it's not that guys lips,
it's the guy below him is the,
the,
the guy who is not moving at all.
They're actually using his facial features and like the of his facial features.
It's really weird.
Yeah.
You're not gonna be able to trust shit in the future.
Definitely not.
Yeah.
I mean,
it's probably already happened.
We just don't know me.
If we're watching this on youtube,
what does the CIA have right now?
Yeah.
You know,
I mean,
they,
they must have some insane shit.
By the way,
speaking of the CIA,
uh,
Neil degrasse Tyson talked to Edward Snowden for a two episodes of is a star
talk podcast.
It's a must listen,
so I'm must listen.
It's amazing.
Fresnel Snowden's a lot fucking smarter than I thought it was because I remember
I'm thinking like,
wow,
like this guy,
like he was a high school dropout and all of a sudden he's working for the NSA
and you know,
or the CIA or whatever.
He was working for gathering data.
Like why don't they let a high school drama?
But then you,
you hear a story and you realize what he actually did wind up going to college
and did wind up going to school and just,
he would just had to kind of a tumultuous slide.
But he was working for the NSA when he was like 16.
Like he's a super genius.
I'm just his,
he didn't graduate from high school.
When you listen to him talk,
he's very fucking smart and he's very well read and understands exactly what the
problems with all of this technology and this,
uh,
uncheck surveillance.
I mean,
he's a hero.
Well,
that I,
I don't,
you know,
I know some people have differing opinions on him,
but he,
that guy enlightened us to the activities of the government that what they were
doing something that was illegal.
They were doing something that 99% of people are going to have a real problem
with spying on people that haven't done anything wrong,
and it's a,
it's fascinating to listen to him talk.
He also had some really interesting shit to say about aliens,
which I thought was really crazy.
He was like in a really complex,
super advanced society.
They're going to have compressed data,
like everything's going to be compressed and everything's going to be encrypted,
and when you have compressed and encrypted data,
it's going to be indistinguishable from background noise.
It's like you're not going to know what you're listening to.
So if you're listening to like some super advanced aliens communications and
you're catching them through the air,
good luck trying to figure out what that is like.
They're not broadcasting like unless they're trying to reach us using our own
primitive methods.
They're not broadcasting like that anymore.
Like they're,
if they're advanced enough so they can get here from another planet,
most likely they're encrypting everything and everything is,
you know,
it's kind of we're,
we're going to hear it.
It's going to sound like background noise.
We're not going to know what the fuck it is,
but to them it's going to be,
you know,
it's going to go into their super advanced systems and it will be clear as day
what to us it's like trying to send an internet signal to someone who was on the
Santa Maria back in the Columbus days.
They'd be like,
what the fuck you doing?
I sent you the email,
you sent me the email.
I'm on a boat here.
I'm getting scurvy.
What do you mean?
He said,
what the fuck's in email?
What are you talking about?
Dude?
Check your phone.
Check my what?
Like
they won't even know what you're talking about.
Right?
Well you think about what that is.
Think of that,
that sort of electronic communication that just a few hundred years ago is
completely alien and out of the question to the point where they would not be
able to even conceptualize what you're saying.
Have you tried to explain something to them?
My friend keeps sending me these Dick pics a phone.
He'd be like,
what the fuck are you talking about?
Now think of that and now extrapolate to a society that's a thousand years more
advanced than us or a million years more advanced than us.
And it's the same sort of lack of ability to recognize what they're doing unless
the technology and the science was so good,
how it should be that there was like a downgrade a bubble.
Like it detects our language and goes,
okay,
this is English around the year 2015 I will now convert it to a understandable,
you know,
communication like well that's if they were trying to communicate with us.
That's what I said earlier.
If they chose to send something non encrypted,
but the problem is they're going to be communicating with each other.
It's like if we chose to talk to someone,
if we could,
we had a time machine and we can go back to Columbus.
We would get him a scroll,
you know,
and it would have some writing on it.
We could do that.
It'd be easy as fuck if we actually wanted to communicate with them.
But if Columbus was out there in the middle of the fucking ocean and he didn't
know he had five bars on his phone and he didn't know his awesome Wifi.
W He has no idea.
He's just out there.
There's nothing out here.
What do I do?
I'm on my own.
You're not on your own pitch.
Plot your phone.
He doesn't have a phone.
So like the,
the ability to do something in the future might be completely outside of our,
our imagination right now are completely outside of our comprehension front page
of CNN right now.
Uh,
supposedly some high school kids,
uh,
hacked,
the private accounts of CIA and homeland security chiefs.
Yeah.
And did you hear where he was doing?
They hacked his account.
He was on fucking all these old men.
Yeah.
These old fucks.
We need to get them out.
Get outta here grandpa.
Oh my God.
Search your file
file.
Excuse me.
It was on the American.
What is AOL stand for?
America Online America Online.
It is a giant corporation.
I have never heard of them being hacked in the past.
AOL email account associated with Brennan that included,
what does it say?
Included files regarding your security was security clearance application and
the hacker also claims to have access to Comcast account associated with
Johnson.
Another old man,
another old man.
It doesn't know what the fuck is going on with the world of technology.
God dammit.
Hey.
Oh Man,
what the fuck is that guy running the fucking secret
service CIA director.
That's what he is.
Jesus Christ.
I wonder if that was just like his email.
Look at these two guys probably picked up dudes.
Look at their two positions.
The CIA director and the Director of Homeland Security,
Jesus Christ,
the Department of Homeland Security Secretary,
but Jesus Christ,
those are,
those are fucking big people.
That's,
you know,
that's not the guy who was the plumber.
Oh,
the guy who was the plumber.
The CIA still use AOL.
Tell him he can't tell him to get on the edu or what would they have?
G.
Dot.
Gov Email list along with fucking Hillary Clinton that control in it for
everybody.
Which a private emails Hillary Clinton and just see what's said in her email.
Well,
they got ahold of her emails,
you know,
because they were,
um,
they were concerned that she was emailing from a private account.
It shows that Tony Blair and George W.
Bush,
we're trying to make plans to go into Iraq a year before they did,
like they were already like,
we're going to Iraq.
Right.
We're going in like right away.
They were,
they were planning on doing that.
They,
I think they said from 2002 there was a emails where they were talking about
doing it so that before they even announced that they were doing it,
they were already trying to figure it out.
Old people did you God damn old people should all have to fucking go to war.
You should have to be,
it should.
War should be for people over 50.
That's it.
Everybody under 50.
Look,
you,
you lived your life,
bitch.
You need to go over there and start shooting people.
US,
we have to,
I have two more years.
I,
we us,
we have to,
we have to.
Yeah.
We have to figure this world out.
You've left us with a mess.
So you guys need to go to war.
You're the ones who want to fight all the time.
Oh yeah.
Okay.
Go to war.
Go over there.
He fuck.
See Hillary Clinton with a machine gun storming the beach.
You watching any of the debate?
Did you follow that whole Bernie Sanders Time Warner's CNN thing at all?
What about the Time Warner's,
uh,
so Bernie,
lot of people think Bernie won like,
like online online polls to the Twitter.
Google,
if you search his name for the most part,
everyone say Bernie was way ahead of it,
but not the news,
but not CNN.
Even on CNN,
his own website,
they had a poll during the debate and Bernie Sanders was that 75% to Clinton was
at 18%,
but they still declared Hillary Clinton the winner of the debate on CNN.
Uh,
that's judging last comic standing.
You know,
you can't judge the winner of a debate,
right?
It's just always going to be someone unless they're,
one of them's like,
you know,
Dan Quayle or someone totally incompetent sh.
So find out that CNN,
uh,
owned by Time Warner,
Time Warner is the seventh largest campaign tribute or to Hillary Clinton,
like over,
I think it was hundreds and hundreds of thousands of dollars
Time Warner as donated to Hillary course course.
I'm sure there's an agenda.
I mean we're,
we're like laughing.
You know,
those thieves,
they robbed somebody.
What's hot?
Did they really rob somebody?
That's crazy.
The thieves rob people like were like surprised that some greasy politician had
her greasy hands and some of the greasy company.
That's true.
Look what they did.
The Ron Paul and then when Ron Paul was doing those debates and smashing people
and they may,
they,
he was ahead of people in the race and they would look at the people below him
as qualified,
sincere candidates and they would look at Ron Paul.
Well,
it's just a matter of time before Ron Paul's out of the race.
But you know,
that's not what he's supposed to do.
When you're a journalist,
when you're a journalist,
you're supposed to look at the actual event and look at the actual facts of the
event and then break down.
What's interesting about the trend,
but they didn't do that.
They put a spin on the trend and it's a spin was clearly that Ron Paul was a
kook and that this wasn't going to last.
Even though you've got people wearing Ron Paul for president shirts and cheering
and screaming.
W how do your,
so you are smarter than them to the point where you're going to dictate how the
information,
the news is getting to these people with a biased spin that makes that guy look
like a Kook.
Like that's a Fox News did.
That's what a lot of people did.
That's what they're going to do to Bernie Sanders.
They're scared of that guy.
Yeah.
CNN deleted the pole.
I mean,
like
they deleted the post.
Find the pole,
find out to find the email.
I can find the,
um,
the,
the uh,
saved image.
Here it is on the pole.
I sent it in the email.
It's a right there.
Okay.
When you say right there,
what am I supposed to see this somewhere.
Oh,
well we'll show it to me.
Oh my God.
That's hilarious.
Yeah.
You silly fucks.
Good Lord.
Why did they think they can do that?
Why would they delete that?
It's amazing.
Kind of scary though.
The Hillary pay 11% yeah.
Yeah.
He stumped her.
God,
75% well,
you know what that is?
That's the online trolls.
When people don't go along with your opinion,
they're trolls.
O'Malley,
you're out.
We can't have red people.
I mean,
we can have native Americans,
but you can't be totally red.
That's a boozer.
He's either boozing or he fell asleep while he's drunk and he got a sunburn.
Look at that guy.
He's an Irish guy with a big red face.
That's ridiculous.
You can't be in there.
How did he get anything?
I never heard of that guy.
If I haven't heard of you by now.
It's over.
Yeah,
throwing the towel.
This is the black guy who doesn't believe in evolution.
There's the Hillary who's got the bad email account and there's Bernie Sanders
wants to give away everybody's money.
But apparently economists looked at Bernie Sanders plans for reducing deficit
and like,
what if this doesn't work like I,
I don't think anybody looks at it and goes,
this is a wonderful idea that fix our problems.
He's a serious hardcore socialist and a lot of ways,
but I think that's good.
It's good to have a guy like that starting it up.
If that got got into power,
listen,
it's fucking better than having another neo-con.
It's way better than having another Dick Cheney behind the fucking puppet stand
was hand up George Bushes ass that fucked us.
Those eight years fucked us.
They changed the tone of our country.
They went from a a time where there was this,
this feeling of America where everybody was sympathetic,
where people were making new and even Paris,
they're putting other newspaper.
We're all Americans today.
I mean,
it was,
it was a amazing time where a horrible thing happened and the whole world came
to us and they came to us and they extended their,
their love and friendship and what do we do?
Which started invading pitches.
We invaded people that didn't have anything to do with it.
We fucked up to the point where eight years later,
everybody hated us.
Everybody went from loving America to why were you in Iraq?
Like,
what do you do?
There's no weapons there.
There's nothing that you guys are assholes.
What are you doing with all that oil?
What do you know what?
Oh,
you just rebuilding shit.
What are you doing?
You just have no wait.
You have no bid contracts for billions of dollars.
What?
Hold on.
You're fucking vice president was the CEO of the company that gets the no bid
contracts.
They are you.
I said that fucking transparent.
That it's that transparent.
That's what happened.
That those people fucked us.
If we had Obama in office,
say what you want about Obama,
but Obama would've never,
it w there was no wet unless,
unless the president has no fucking say whatsoever on how things go down,
unless it's that dirty,
there's no way that guy would have approached it the same way.
There's no way he would've come up with some reason why we had to invade Iraq.
I say that,
but he did want us to invade Syria and people were like,
what?
I remember that.
That doesn't come up anymore.
Does it,
do you think should end it.
Do you think news should be put under stricter guidelines for,
you know,
like,
like that?
Should it be illegal?
You know,
CNN picking aside,
giving money to a president and then announcing it or look at the former Fox guy
that just got arrested for sending,
you know,
fabricating a,
a fake CIA past or Bryan Adams who you know,
Brian Williams,
Bryan Adams.
He's released a CD that covered the whole Taylor swift album.
I highly recommended he re reimagine Taylor Swiss whole album.
Oh boy.
That's been a real dark,
dark.
Doesn't sound like Taylor swift.
Is it like,
uh,
like when Garth Brooks had his alter ego,
it's
kind of like Willie Nelson covering a nine inch nails.
Know,
eat Johnny Cash.
Not Willie Nelson.
Yeah.
Jesus Christ.
Eddie Murphy told the Bill Cosby joke is that he got an award for the Mark Twain
Comedy Award that's going to be on PBS and he actually did like a whole bit
cities right in comedy again.
Yeah.
TMC had him on yesterday saying he was gonna he should,
he should just go full Jim Norton.
Look,
I like trainees.
This is what you should just do and come back to the fold.
Just tell us who you are,
who you got.
You can't.
Your Dick sucked by dudes,
but you're really straight.
That's okay.
You're Eddie Murphy,
man.
She could come clean but he can't,
you know,
it's,
it's different man.
It's different.
Like the black community has different rules.
Dev deferrals,
which you can and can't do and some things you need to keep under wraps.
I don't know if he picks those trans gender prostitutes up just because he was a
nice guy and he wants to give him a ride home or if he really likes them.
But according to my buddy who was on the force back then that he's actually been
there while I went down there like it wasn't,
those wasn't just one.
Wow.
He likes him,
which is fine.
Like Norton talks about it all the time.
People joke about it all the time and everybody loves Norton.
If you don't Love Norton,
go fuck yourself.
How about that?
And I think if Eddie Murphy just came clean,
do people turn on though all the people that voted for proposition eight that
was when,
when they found out that Ari had a great joke about that,
but black people want to quality.
Everybody was like talking about a quality except the gays like Nope,
not you.
You can't,
can't get married like black people like overwhelmingly voted.
Again,
the against or for proposition eight which repealed gay marriage.
There's like Mormons.
Mormons spent a lot of money on it and a lot of black people voted for religion,
religion,
strong and black.
Yeah,
but it's also the gay thing.
It's like a,
there's a certain amount of homophobia that's accepted in certain parts of the
African American community.
I was a very politically correct way of saying that black folks don't like gays
and then it's not even all gays,
man.
It's just,
you can't really talk about it too much.
But what is the bill Cosby joke he told?
Oh,
you mean play it?
Sure.
That's all it took a minute.
Let's do it.
Play it.
We're going to get pulled off youtube while we're on youtube.
I'll just play the audio.
Okay.
Oh,
and if you are tuning into this now and you look good,
too immature Brogan,
would you post the wrong link on Ustream?
I made a mistake.
Sorry.
Uh,
I've been doing Ustream for six years.
But the other thing about it is that you can,
on Youtube,
one of the reasons why we decided to do it on youtube is you can just rewind it
to the beginning.
Even though it's streaming.
You can go back to the beginning.
Oh really?
Yeah.
It's a,
it's a,
it's a superior platform.
You'll make bill give his event.
It was a big outcry from people.
It was trying to get bill to give his trophies back.
No,
you wouldn't want you to give you the trophies.
[inaudible] he said do one show.
We just come out and just talk crazy.
Now I would like to talk to
some of the people who
that I should give back my time.
[inaudible]
it.
They said they go,
he goes on a little bit longer,
but this doesn't air on p until November 23rd on coach.
So they don't,
they want you to tune in duty.
I like his timing.
He should come back with truing,
kill it,
look all that training stuff aside.
Who cares about that stuff?
He's one of the all time greats.
Eddie Murphy when not not um,
raw.
I think rob was as good is delirious but delirious at the time.
Good Lord.
That was good.
He was on fire.
It was so powerful.
Imagine him just hanging out at the store.
Again,
too many people with swarm him.
It's hard for us.
It's hard for you.
You get swarmed at the store.
Imagine if you're Eddie Murphy stores filled with Weirdos.
It's a magnet for Weirdos.
It's always been a magnet for Weirdos.
It's gotten,
gotten crazy lately,
too crazy.
That's why they have the rope off in the parking lot and to tell people you
can't go near the cars cause people are back in their cars out.
This is a bunch of drunks wander into the parking lot.
You know,
trying to,
uh,
take a picture with Steve Run is easy and they getting run over by cars.
Um,
this,
this thing,
this article that I want to talk problem,
we got here,
a transgender woman.
Um,
she was a woman.
She applied to an all male,
all female college.
Well was Wellesley,
Wellesley college ice.
Actually,
uh,
no girl from Wellesley back in the day,
um,
was an all girls' campus.
And um,
so she applied for the college.
She was born a female but then decided to transition into,
uh,
she had a very hilarious,
this is hilarious.
Listen to the description of how she introduces himself herself.
Whatever masculine of center.
Gender Queer.
Exactly.
Yeah.
I,
I am in love with this story.
I am in love with these kinds of people.
I am in love with people that are so fucking preposterous that they take
preposterous to an art form and they,
they,
they become living parody whether they like it or not.
Listen to what the fuck I just said.
She goes to a college,
she applies to an all girls college,
is super liberal,
all
gone,
all girls college.
She decides that she is transgender and decides that she wants to,
she introduces herself as masculine of center gender queer changes her name to
Timothy decided that she's Timothy and asked people to use the male pronoun when
referring to him.
Okay,
so welcome on campus until the day that she announced he announced,
okay,
it's,
he now whatever,
that he wanted to run for the school's Office of multicultural affairs
coordinator whose job is to promote a cultural,
a culture of diversity now who you would think would need diversity more than
someone who's a transgender man.
You know?
I mean that's,
that's a very small segment of the population and they're often maligned and you
know,
this is a socially marginalized group and it would be nice for an open minded
liberal college to accept someone like this and to recognize what a perfect
person to be a part of our campaign.
Encouraging people to,
uh,
you know,
to,
to be more open minded and accept people.
No,
they attacked her because now they felt that she is a white man and they don't
want a white man in that position because of a white man is in that position.
Then they're supporting the patriarchy.
So there was three other candidates for the Gig,
right?
All women of color.
Wonderful.
If one of them win and then you got,
okay,
you know what your problem solved.
You got a woman of color in that position.
Plenty of diversity there.
You're good,
right?
No,
they all dropped out and then they stayed at,
they started an anonymous Facebook campaign encouraging people not to vote at
all,
to keep a white man from winning the position.
Ah,
this is amazing.
This is the left eating itself.
That's what's happening.
They're eating themselves.
It is a feeding frenzy.
I used to have Paranas.
Okay,
and one of the things about [inaudible] is,
well,
one gets a limp.
They just jacked that motherfucker.
They are the most ruthless cunts.
When one Parana would just be,
you know,
sometimes you have a fish tank,
one fish,
we'll just start swimming weird.
They start swimming kind of half sideways for some reason.
You're like,
is that fish okay?
And you have to look at him like,
what's going on with that fish?
That shit didn't last in that tank baby.
All those motherfuckers are just,
they just started taking chunks out of them.
That's what's happening here.
The left is they're turning on themselves.
They've run out of outrage.
They've made so many safe places.
They don't want anything to be safe anymore and they want to be able to go to
war over everything.
They're ferocious there.
Paranas their social idea Paranas and they're attacking a gender.
Quill,
Gender Queer,
masculine of center man for not being diverse enough for being a part of the
patriarchy,
Bardo woman board.
A woman lived as a woman.
Nope,
you're a white man now.
You fucking piece of shit.
You're a part of the problem.
Makes no sense.
It does make sense though.
It makes sense because it highlights what this movement is all about.
It's socially retarded.
People that are left alone to their own devices and they're just devouring each
other like zombies.
They just tearing into each other like,
like zombies at a trapped into a fucking room.
It doesn't raw.
They just ripping each other apart.
You're not diverse enough.
You're not progressive enough.
Fuck you.
You're such a pig.
I'm triggered.
They just trigger each other left and right.
This is,
uh,
this is an onion article.
This is a fucking onion article and it's not,
this is the national review.
This is a goddamn onion article and it's not transgender woman can't be
diversity officer because she's a white man now.
Yeah.
Mixed 0 million cents makes all the sense in the world.
It's not a fake article.
I mean that seems like a hundred percent perfect.
It's perfect.
It's amazing.
It's beautiful.
It's a rose is a rose in a bad neighborhood.
It pops out of the concrete and it comes out perfect.
It's amazing.
This is art.
It's,
it's the universe creating art with our own folly.
That's what it is.
It's culture.
It's called [inaudible].
It's people,
you know.
There's something that happens to people when you deny reality when you don't
look at things objectively like there's,
there's I think like priest at molests kids,
right?
Some of that has to be from suppression.
Some of it has to be probably they were abused themselves.
There's probably all sorts of,
but some of that perversion has got to come from suppression.
It's like the Catholic school girl thing that everybody knows.
You know,
when I was in high school,
there was no scientists in my fucking ninth grade class,
but we all knew the girls went to Catholic schools were hose and why are they
hose the hose?
Because everybody tells them they can't be a Ho.
Everybody's talking to them constantly about,
you are going to go to hell,
do not touch a man's genitals,
don't you do anything.
Those costs were freaks.
They were the biggest freaks and we all knew it.
It was.
There was no books on it.
There was no youtube videos that we could watch,
but we fucking knew it.
Man.
We all knew it and I think it's a suppression issue and this is suppressing
individual identity.
This is suppressing free speech.
This is suppressing objectivity.
You're not allowed to have unique or intertwined thoughts.
You're not allowed to share opinions with the left and with the right.
You're not allowed to.
You have to have,
and you're constantly worried about being called out.
You're constantly worried about being outed and doxed and called out and shamed.
Everyone's shaming people and attacking people and it's this fucking feeding
frenzy.
I love it.
I'm happy.
I'm so happy when I read a story like this.
I would encourage this woman to fight to the death her position.
Oh man,
she's a man now.
Fight to the death for that position.
I mean literally,
I want you to show up for school in a fucking an armor with a sword and let them
know that you are,
you are here because you are a warrior for diversity and you're going to get,
you're going to take this to the very end,
to the very end of time.
Oh,
it's amazing.
This is an amazing story.
It's like one of the greatest stories the universe has ever told cause it's,
it's just,
and it,
it highlights that story that we were just talking about where the,
um,
the thing that was up on the,
uh,
the thing earlier with the,
the,
the United States is like a powder keg.
This is like what we're talking about,
like entitled ridiculous people that they don't live in reality.
You're,
you're,
you're not,
and you're,
you're concentrating on nonsense.
But why they concentrating on nonsense because they don't have to worry about
feeding themselves.
They don't have to worry about shelter.
They don't have to worry about being in Ohio having no fucking power for a week
and everybody has to stay alive.
You can't get to work.
Everybody's like walking back and forth to each other's house,
Sharon food and going out and getting firewood together and dragging it back at
some little kids wagon.
That's what people do when they want to survive.
When,
when you want to survive,
you come up with ways that you could all work together.
When it's too easy to survive,
you start attacking people for nonsense and that's what the fuck is going on
here.
You got to campaign to keep,
we're going to make sure that a white man,
it's not going to win this.
Like as if she's really a white man.
Why are we pretending that's a man left of Queer Gender Queer masculine of
center.
Shut the fuck up.
You're a girl,
you're a girl or a guy,
whatever you are.
Who cares what the fuck it was probably way more to this story.
She's just a big bitch and I like,
she's just kind of got,
we just eating too much pussy on campus.
They're all mad.
Yeah,
so it's just too good at it.
She's too good at it.
But she's gender queer,
so that means I don't think he'd do anything.
I don't know what that means.
I don't even think they know what it means.
But you know what?
You've heard of pansexual.
There was a woman who was like,
she was making history.
This is hilarious.
This is a hilarious story.
She's making history because she was the first Gen.
Oh she was the first pan sexual person to take office
pants.
What the fuck are you talking about?
What does that mean to me?
And she doesn't sexually identify.
She's not particularly sexually attracted to either race or either gender.
It's either one or both.
Miley Cyrus pansexual,
of course she is.
That's called being a freak.
Pansexual.
What exactly does that mean?
But go find the politician first politician as pansexual.
It's just so stupid.
Pen Sexual politician.
Since like a new word for bisexual,
it's not even bisexual.
It's cause like they have to be special and that it has to be met.
Mary Texas state representative identifies as pansexual in new interview.
First of all,
good for her.
Eat that pussy.
Suck that Dick.
Have a party.
Honey,
I'm not hating.
Do whatever you want,
but do we really have to make it new name for it?
Fucking Christ.
I and I,
I,
I posted something about this awhile back on Twitter and there was people that
were defending the term pansexual.
I'm like,
fuck you.
Fuck you for trying to muddy up the war.
Fuck you for having this on your mind.
Unless you're mocking it.
Fuck you for taking this seriously.
Fuck you for this being an actual thing.
When you want to debate it,
how bad is your job?
How bored are you at work that you're sitting in front of your Twitter account
defending pansexuality you stop.
You stop.
I'm saying she could do it.
I have no problem with,
you know,
don't get me wrong,
but you fucking stop.
If you think you're going to defend that,
fuck you.
You need to go cut snow cuts.
No need to go.
Countries need to go cut trees and shovel snow over Jamie's parents house in the
middle of the winter when the fucking power's off for a month.
That's what you need to do.
You need to dig Brian red bands.
Mom out of the fucking woods.
Dig Out of the woods.
It's a mile dirt road back to that lady's house.
Get get going.
Fuck face.
That's like,
what does that,
how many thousand feet is a mile?
5,000.
5,000 plus feet of snow shoveling.
You fuck how much for the driveway?
Do you remember that you've ever,
that when you're a kid you'd go to a lady's house and uh,
ma'am,
we're,
we're shoveling stone.
Well,
how much for the driveway?
Like,
oh,
we're going to need 20 for this one.
That's too much.
It's a long driveway,
man.
It was going to take us a couple hours.
Oh,
that's just too much.
They would get mad at you.
Not Miss those days are having to mow people's lawns.
She just take her to not miss it.
Miss Mowing.
I hated mowing lawns.
I was watching Anthony Bourdain show last night.
He did a special on a San Francisco is pretty bad ass.
But um,
then I watched one that I had on the DVR.
I was doing some work,
so I was like,
just kind of like half watching it while I was working on the laptop and uh,
he had one from Montreal in the middle of the winter and you're like,
oh Jesus,
I forgot.
I forgot what that was like.
Oof.
They're just all bundled up outside.
Everyone's face is beat red.
Every breath that comes out of your mouth is frozen because that place is wet.
That's a wet cold too.
That's a by the ocean cold zero degrees by the ocean is a mother fucker.
Dude,
that's not like the cryotherapy tank.
I got some new videos that you have to watch.
Sometimes it's a semi a dude's Dick.
The other day that dude dancing and pulls his dick out.
Will you let you send them to me so much
that I accuse you of sending me a guy's Dick and you're like,
why didn't eh,
well,
it sometimes people will send me shit and I immediately just send it to whoever
is these.
These guys made this a
prank video and what they did is they took a taser and they put it in the seat
of a bicycle and attached it to a cell phone so he can,
you can call it and make,
activate the Taser.
Then they took,
went to Compton and just like put their bike down,
you know,
and waited until somebody stole their bike.
And so then you see people like writing,
like taking off and then they like called the cell phone and it uh,
shocks their balls.
You know why they're sitting on the bike?
So they just fall off the bike.
That's like an advanced version of that.
A Bait car show?
Yes.
Yeah.
And then they have it,
there
is this other guy that just attached a rope to it,
like a secret little like rope to it.
So people like grabbed the bike and take off down this hill and then when the
rope catches up it just throws the bike back and they just rack their balls.
Like,
God,
all these people are just breaking balls and like,
but they,
they would feet.
So who cares?
You know
it's a loophole,
right?
You could get really fucked up doing that.
Like it hurt bad.
Yeah,
but they're stealing.
So who gives a fuck?
I know I'm addicted to these new things like these bait card things and bait
bikes.
So
main Edwards has a hilarious bit.
Ian Has a hilarious bit on that bait car show.
Oh yeah.
Oh,
it's so funny.
In San Diego,
right?
Yeah.
He worked with Ian San Diego Friday night.
Fuck.
He's funny man.
He's such a good dude too.
He's one of those guys and he's been writing for shows forever,
so he hasn't been like touring a lot and doing the road a lot.
But,
but he's also been doing comedy for like 25 years.
He's one of the best guys in the world.
He really is.
He's like,
if there's one guy that people just don't know about that I go,
God damn.
People should know about Ian Edwards.
Like people are knowing about Thompson grow now.
I mean,
he's doing his second Netflix special.
Just did it.
You know,
everything's going great for him.
Rei,
obviously everything's going great for our Dunkin.
If he just would put out some content.
Like doc is brilliant.
His comedy is amazing,
he's excellent.
He just doesn't put anything out.
He doesn't do,
he doesn't do any fucking specials.
He's actually really heard anything from Dunkin in a while like online or it's
hard to find a stand up.
You know what I mean?
He works all the time and he was at the store the other night killing it.
It's still hilarious.
He just doesn't put anything out.
He,
he's constantly working on his podcast.
I think Dunkin likes doing podcasts more than anything,
which is fine cause it's,
it's amazing.
I mean it's a really good,
he's really good at it.
He's one of the best ranters like Dunkin.
Like when you do podcasts with him,
one of the things that happens,
you got to know like when to back off and just let it go.
Let them rant because you don't want to trip up what he's doing because he gets
in these like these like linguistic waves that he starts riding and he just says
this amazing colorful way of describing things and sometimes he'll paint a
picture that you wouldn't expect or you wouldn't have ever painted without it.
It's,
and that's,
that's something that you don't really do when you do stand up in a way.
Cause like the beauty of his style
of,
of doing podcasts,
the entertaining aspect of it doesn't translate into anything else,
but it does a little bit to stand up.
But really it's just a beautiful style of ranting about subjects.
That's great for a podcast.
It makes it look super enjoyable and interesting.
But to that,
I think that to him is more exciting and more fun than podcasts and it's
certainly reaches more people or comedy me.
Yeah.
Then then comedy.
Yeah,
because it's certainly reaches more people because obviously if he's doing the
show and unless he's putting it out on Netflix or comedy central or something
like that,
I mean he's doing standup for a couple hundred people at a time or a thousand
people at the most,
you know.
But if he's doing that podcast,
his podcast is hitting hundreds of thousands every month.
He's,
he's always been one of my favorite standups.
You know,
when we first moved out here,
I would like goes to almost all his comedy shows with them,
you know?
And just because I had no friends,
so I'd like go with him.
He,
he's one of the funnest people to watch on stage,
especially when he had little Hobo and just like somebody stole it.
Yeah.
I know it's San Francisco,
but I,
there's people like him I wish would do more standup.
Like he does Swartz in,
yeah.
I love Nick.
He does stand up a lot.
He just doesn't put anything out right.
And I just think he needs to put together a special,
so good man.
He's so fucking funny.
But,
but everybody knows Dunkin.
You know,
I think a lot of people know Dunkin because of the podcast world.
Ian is a guy who doesn't really have a big,
he was doing something with you for a while,
right?
The preposterous sessions kind of do what I do with the roast battle.
It just replayed it on desk squad for him.
Oh,
so it was his place,
his initials trying to help him out with the,
yeah,
he needs to,
I don't know what it is.
I think you just need to not write anymore on those shows because when you write
on those shows,
you can't tour.
You're stuck.
He was,
he just turned down a big gig because they told him that he couldn't pitch
anything else.
They told him,
uh,
you know,
Kim Kim was going through this some shit right now with this.
These companies,
they get you and then they say that they own you intellectually,
not just while you're working there.
Like say if you write on a show,
right.
They don't want,
they want you to not just write on that show.
They want to own you.
If you have a movie script that you're writing on the side,
they want to own you.
If you have a book,
they decide because they can,
because they're,
their model is kind of rotting away.
Like the model of the Sitcom.
That's a fucking,
they used to be a lot of sitcoms back in the day,
like in the 90s when I was on news radio,
everything was a sitcom.
There was four or five sitcoms a night and you know you had sex in the city,
you had friends,
you had the single guy,
you had Caroline in the city for sex in the city.
I was confusing him.
You,
you know you had all these different networks that all these different shows.
Everybody had sitcoms.
He had four or five sitcoms a week,
six,
seven sitcoms a week,
whatever the fuck the number was.
He had dramas,
all these different shows.
They're dying now.
They have a few,
you know you have like undateable this doing that weird shit where they're
trying to do a live version of it.
Yeah.
We'll talk about that.
And then you have like,
I guess two broke girls is still doing Freilla Big Bang theory is Big Bang
theory.
It seems to me like,
like a,
you know how they do that music that they play for the Cobra,
Eh,
and then the Cobra,
just like he can't move,
he gets hypnotized by the music.
I think that is what happens with retards.
When they watched the Big Bang theory,
I think it's somehow or another guest them to tune in just long enough to play
those commercials and then it ends and they go,
what just happened?
And they wake up.
What did I just watch?
There's only a few now though.
So because of that,
they want to own everybody.
They want to own,
they want to own all the stuff he did.
Now what our friend Kim,
it gets even crazier because she's not even a writer.
She's employed as a secretary for a company.
And this the company that she's employed,
four options.
Yeah,
same thing.
Yeah.
The company that she's employed for wants to own a project that she's created.
Well,
I kind of her own,
I kind of get where they're coming from.
How um,
because she works at a place that there's a lot of,
they make a lot of shows.
All right.
So she has to interact with a lot of important people.
She sees a lot of things behind the scenes.
So what they do that for is like a basic thing in Hollywood.
So where she can't tell the competition like,
Oh hey,
you know,
a Jeff Foxworthy is going to be on the next show and uh,
it's just a confidentiality waiver there.
They're pretty much saying is that's not according to her.
I think you're wrong.
I've read what she said and once you sent me,
right.
She,
she,
I talked to her last night and she said she made it seem like their reasoning is
that they don't want me to create like the,
like the like a show using secrets that they use,
you know,
on the side,
like,
cause she's open.
She's who a lot of secrets.
A lot of
the words.
Yeah.
We own your brain.
Yeah,
that's what they said there.
Yeah.
A lot of places.
We own your brain while you work here.
We own your brain.
That's retarded.
I don't give a fuck what reasoning they have.
She's a secretary or receptionist,
whatever.
She answers phones.
If they wanted to sign a confidentiality agreement you do that.
But the idea that they say that her,
we own your brain,
they want to own her project,
they want to own the projects that she creates.
That particular,
I think things she worked for though is very close to TV shows.
So like they can't have somebody just making and TV shows based off secrets that
the secrets,
see look,
if you smell something,
but what does that look?
That's the purpose of her working for some place where you making shit money
when you work as an intern.
So if you work for an intern for the opiate Anthony show or whatever,
they're,
the reason why you're not,
they're not paying you shit is because you're learning about the business.
Like,
good,
well we're going to not pay you anything and then what are you going to do?
You got to learn shit
here.
And the figured out on your own and then you can't be my slave anymore.
That's ridiculous that that company's full of cuts that that's a country
company.
Like why?
Why would he,
why are you paying her five bucks an hour?
They're like wait,
or whatever.
She's getting some getting much like Wah.
That's the whole purpose of working in a,
an entry level Gig is you supposed to learn,
well you're going to took it and you're going to learn.
You need going to go profit elsewhere.
It's one thing if she steals an idea,
she steals an idea,
they should sewer.
But if she's not stealing ideas,
if she just learning about the business and you're trying to penalize her or
you're trying to,
they're trying to own what she's doing,
you know,
not just like kinda own it,
but according to her,
they want to own it.
They want to own everything she does when she works there.
That's crazy.
But that's also why he shouldn't have a job like that.
She should just be a comic.
Just struggle.
Get a waitress job.
You know this,
this,
everybody wants to
like nothing wrong with waitress jobs.
They're fine.
It's good.
Unless you waitressing on fat Tuesday at the comedy store.
Fuck,
that doesn't exist anymore.
Do you watch the daily show?
Do you like this new guy?
Cause I saw you tweet something the other day about it and I don't know if you
actually,
I mean I tried to watch it.
I'm not on board with that guy.
I haven't seen it yet.
Um,
but there,
there's a,
there's a Russell Peters thing.
We're,
Russell Peters said that the guy's a thief.
And then after he said,
uh,
you know,
he said the guy stole from him,
guys stole from someone else.
I saw the bit that Russell said he stole from him.
It's the same exact premise.
And if you saw Russell do it,
that's probably exactly where he got it from.
And then there was a thing where he recently did a bit,
there was a straight up Dave Chappelle bit from like a,
the early two thousands,
right?
Yeah.
And uh,
100% that was banked.
It was the same.
It wasn't,
it was the same wording.
Same premise,
same everything,
and it's a Dave Chappelle bit,
so you know that bit.
So if you're a standup comic,
you know that bit.
I mean it's like Louis C.
Case bag of Dicks joke.
There's like jokes that like you kind of know or like a Cosby.
Yeah,
yeah.
The Noah's Ark bit or like a,
you know,
Richard Pryor's vampire bit vampire in the hood.
You know that bit man,
there's a class at Sam Kinison is having sex with the homosexual necrophiliac
joke.
That bit,
you know that bit.
People know that bit.
So if you,
if you try to steal that,
come on son,
you can't,
then you get it.
He didn't,
didn't mix it up a little,
but he,
he mixed it up a little with,
uh,
with Russell,
you could tell the origin was most likely the same.
Did he probably saw Russell do it,
but it's a race joke and it's vague enough.
So,
and the way he did,
he did,
he danced around it enough.
Yeah.
Russell in that interview,
by the way,
that woman that interviewed Ralph Soul in that,
oh my gosh.
She's like,
she's not jealous cause he's hotter and skinnier and skinnier.
Cuter.
She said,
Russell,
you can tell he got,
he also mentions another person that he stole from.
I don't know any other comic is,
but it seems like a smoke versus fire thing.
Definitely smoked smoking fire.
Yeah.
Most.
Most likely.
Yeah.
And he's there.
They're hanging
out though.
Do you think that who gives a fuck?
It's not,
it's not.
Dave probably doesn't read low Internet.
He's probably not even online.
Yeah,
it's true.
Probably has no idea it happened.
People getting,
Damn.
I was like,
hmm.
So they stole his jokes,
but their friends.
Well,
okay.
First of all,
if you're a calculated guy like Trevor Noah,
right?
Why wouldn't you do that when you put this up,
what is it a fucking coincidence that a couple of days later he takes his
picture with Dave and who knows when this picture happened?
When?
When did this picture take place?
Did the pig,
but did the photo get taken yesterday?
They went out to dinner or lunch yesterday before that Mark Twain thing that
Eddie Murphy was just app.
There's a bunch of comedians together.
Well who,
okay,
well maybe he,
uh,
you know,
got together with day because he wanted to talk to him about it and tell him he
had no idea or blah,
blah,
blah.
But when Russell did it,
Russell said that he had this massive media backlash after he said the guy was a
thief and then he said it was a prank.
He said it was a prank.
Now in the interest of confidentiality,
I will go no further.
Right.
But you can fucking do the math.
I think my personal gas would be that it wasn't a prank.
Well,
we don't need to go further.
That's what go no further means Brian.
But,
uh,
you know,
Russell's the nicest fucking guy on the planet earth.
He really is.
If Russell Peter says you're a piece of shit,
I,
I tend to,
I tend to agree.
I usually,
I mean,
I don't know,
but it's whatever,
man.
You know,
you also got to realize this fucking dude was doing it in South Africa.
That's like being on the moon.
It's like doing standup on the moon.
I mean there's a few comics there I'm sure,
but they're seen is it's so,
it might have been their style to do other people shit and I'm a not exonerating
him in any way,
but you got to think like if you're at a band,
okay and you're in fucking Florida,
guess what?
You're going to do other people's music.
You know,
if you really want to be a big band and you're learning and one day you guys
want to be huge,
you're going to do some cover songs and in the world of stand up,
you don't do that in the world of stand up.
You can't get away with that.
But I guarantee you there are some people right now that could be really good
comedians some day and they're in some really obscure market in the middle of
nowhere.
Or perhaps they're in some place that speaks Dutch or some places speaks French
and they're stealing some bill Cosby bit right now,
or they're stealing some bill hicks bid right now.
That was always a big thing with Hicks.
There was a guy in Amsterdam,
there was doing standup and Dutch and he was just stealing all of Bill Hicks is
shit.
But some other guy who is bilingual realized it and it was like,
what is this in Montreal?
It's a huge issue.
The French people up there like the,
the French speaking to do French speaking shows and these guys will just gag
dude's material,
just Yank American's material and just translate it into France.
They don't leave that area.
It's a,
it's a very centralized area
like Montreal and Quebec.
Totally like they,
they're very proud.
There's a giant population of French speaking people and you can get away with
doing a French speaking act and steal a bunch of shit.
But if they are doing that,
man,
if they're listening to this,
you got to stop.
It's gonna fuck you up.
It's going to ruin you.
It's going to fuck you up.
Even if you know,
even if you're getting away with it now,
you'll,
you'll develop tendencies and you're going to want to steal when things aren't
going well.
You know,
and that's those moments when things aren't going well.
That's what defines you as a comic.
That's what pulls you out of the fire.
There's moments I will tank bits on purpose when I'm working on shit.
I will take the energy down.
I will,
I will put myself in bad positions because it's the only way you will.
You learn how to get out of them and figure out what if I don't believe in a bit
that much.
I'll do a strong part of a bit and then I'll back off of it and almost like put
myself in a scared spot where I have to flail around to try to find a punchline.
I always have another bit on the ready to jump in with to to bring the crowd
back,
but if you don't do that and everybody does that,
Diaz does it that way.
Our,
he does it that way.
A lot of people do it that way.
We all,
we've talked about it.
We do it that way because that's the way you find CHIBE got to go out in the
deep water and people don't want to go on that deep water.
They,
those guys who steal,
they never go in that deep water man.
They get,
they go into those shallow kill zones and they elect to have these tight,
nice short chopping sets where they,
there's no pause,
Bam,
next joke.
Oh my God.
Was that a pause or they not laughing?
Fuck steel.
And then they'll jump in with a steel and that's dementia approach.
That's why when men see,
would always say he never,
he never bombed ever.
Everybody.
Everybody was like,
what?
Never.
You never bombed dude.
Chappelle bombed a year ago and there's a video of it online.
He in 22,000 people and if he's not the best comic in the world today,
he's top three,
right?
I think the best is Joey.
But Joey's bombed.
I've seen Joe.
Joey called me the other day,
told me,
bombed in Toledo.
Those fucking white people,
Joe Rogan,
those fucking white people hated me.
He goes to desk squat.
People came out,
but those fucking white people,
oh my God,
they hated me.
He was in Toledo.
But you see what I'm saying?
And he's,
in my opinion,
I think Joey's the funniest guy I've ever seen in my life.
I've never seen anybody that makes me laugh as hard as he does and even he can
still bomb.
You can just cause he's out there doing it.
He's got notebooks,
he's fucking flinging jokes around.
You have his days where you're on days where you're off.
That's part of developing and it's constant.
It keeps going.
So these guys like these Trevor Noah Katz,
man,
if that's your tendency,
you're going to keep what?
He's going to be very hard for that dude to break.
Yeah,
that's it's getting,
he might be able to break that tendency because he's famous now.
He might be able to hire writers and he's smart and he's obviously calculating,
which is why I put that photo up.
He didn't put that photo up as a fucking coincidence.
You think he's like,
oh,
I didn't even know that.
People were thinking that I stole that bit and please everybody fucking knows.
Everybody knows.
He knows that everybody knows and he's made,
he made a calculated effort to put up at,
makes me more suspicious of them.
More suspicious if Dave Chappelle put that picture up,
I would be like,
Dave's fuck.
what does Dave doing here?
Is he laughing is as an inside joke but him doing it makes me more suspicious.
It's hard out there for a pimp.
Brian Read Ben,
you know when you going to put together a special
I need to.
I just need to do it.
Yeah,
and I have the material.
I stopped half,
like half hour's worth of material recently.
What do you mean he stopped?
I just stopped doing it.
But you have it written down.
I mean,
yeah,
I have it recorded and it's on video.
You should totally put something out.
Put something out.
Some guy just advertise the other day on Twitter,
like $1,500 four camera shoot.
We'll make your comedy special or something like that.
You know,
100 bucks like,
Hey,
I should just do that for fun.
Does he know what he's doing?
I don't know.
Probably.
It's so easy nowadays.
I mean,
I may remember when I used to go on the road with you all the time,
I would bring three cameras,
have a front back,
two sides.
And that was,
those were shitty little old school cameras.
Two in comparison to what's available today.
Yeah.
But we were on kind of on top of the game on all the cameras.
You would always upgrade them to like the best Sony Cams.
But yeah,
I think,
um,
my next one that I'm going to do,
which I'm going to probably do within the next six months,
I'm working out all the details right now.
I think I'm going to do it at the Ice House.
I'm at the Ice House on October 30th,
too,
by the way.
Me and Ian.
Um,
and maybe Diaz might stop by for the 10 o'clock show,
but,
um,
I think,
that's the future.
I think the future is just doing it old school at a club and you know,
having the production value be in the quality of the video itself so that it
captures the room as accurately as possible.
But don't try to make it like this big swooping camera and all that bullshit.
I want people to feel like they're sitting down in the crowd.
And I think the only way to do that is to put it in a small spot.
Cause uh,
you know,
I'll do big shows,
I'll do these big shows and they're fun.
Man Theaters are fun.
It's a different kind of experience.
But the,
the real show,
we all know the real,
the really fun show that's going to translate into sitting at home and watching
it is like 200 at a comedy club,
especially Ice House.
I love the Ice House so much.
I had some,
one of my favorite sets Friday,
just do stuff and just positive people go their staff,
everything's awesome man.
Well it's got 65 fucking
years of comedy burned into the walls too,
you know.
And also I think I learned something from doing that.
A comedy central special,
the rocky mountain high.
I'm like,
that's the way to do it.
That felt more to me like a regular set than anything else I've ever done.
You could see the audience,
the right there on top of me,
you know,
it was fun.
That's the way to do it.
And the ice house is even better than that.
Ice Houses our home too,
you know,
that's home base.
Other than the comedy store that that place feels like home to me.
Even I do the factory,
I've done the laugh factory.
Who knows how many times over decades still always feels weird.
Yeah man,
the Improv is pretty cool,
but that's not,
you know,
it's not the same.
The Ice House to me is like right up there with the store.
Yeah,
absolutely.
Yeah.
Damn.
Germany orders recalled 8.5 million Volkswagens said they recall yours.
I don't have that anymore.
I got rid of it.
You got rid of it?
Yeah,
they uh,
they fucked up.
They tried to lie.
I think I figured out what car when want get though.
I three that BMW I,
those are dope.
They look like an iPhone on wheels.
It looks cool.
Yeah.
Those are pretty dope.
I think my way to get a used one kind of expensive.
Oh,
are they?
I heard those things break down a lot though.
Is that it right there?
That's the video that autopilot from Tesla.
Oh Jesus.
Play this.
So this is something we've got to leave on this cause I gotta get Outta here.
So this is some update.
Jamie when she explained the update because Tesla,
they did an over the air update,
which is something that I didn't know that they could do,
but they said they're going to do it multiple times and I think it's just in
Beta right now.
Um,
so Tesla has an auto pilot and also an auto park.
The autopilot think it's just made for the freeway right now,
but they've been testing it and there's some videos showing it used in,
uh,
like in New York on 12th Avenue.
And this is,
I think this looks like it's back on like a movie lot and they're showing the,
uh,
that,
that crazy button first.
So it shoots up to 75 miles an hour and then it's going to go into autopilot
mode and you see it like a read street signs and it's reading the white lines on
the road.
She kind of moved her car and then at the very end it will stop it as it sees a
car in front of it too.
I hope this,
this is video from slash gear,
so this was,
shouldn't bother us too much,
but wow.
Just full door.
Sit down and we started over to there.
They're getting ready to launch right now.
So
just look at that fucking screen.
This is on autopilot right now.
Yeah,
that's fast.
Trust.
Just follow.
Sit down in the world.
You say never.
This is not driving itself.
I mean you can't as can turn on the autopilot system.
Engaging it now.
Wow.
Queriness so cool.
The accelerator,
the car will observe the 30 mile an hour sign and increase in speed.
As we go through this bend.
I'd be texting like a motherfucker right now on the road and as it observes this
25 mile an hour speed,
it's going to reduce Jesus Christ and it click the turn signal on where people
are going to fuck around and put 90 on those things.
Just taping it and now the nine,
the car over the too nice.
So many problems.
I can see just with like,
but I'm sure they've thought
there are a lot of things but wow,
that's so,
oh that's amazing.
This guy,
Elon Musk is freaking me out because it makes me feel really stupid,
really stupid and really unambitious and really insignificant.
When I see him with his beautifully tailored suits and he's talking about
changing the world.
I'm like,
am I looking at Tony Stark for real?
This is like,
when is he going to come out with an iron man suit?
Right.
Cause he's gonna you know that fucks got one already.
He's probably gotten one already in his basement.
He's probably all Adderall.
Dot Steve Jobs too.
Right?
Like he's more than to see jobs to me.
Write to me,
he's way more innovative because what Steve Jobs did was amazing,
but it was all in the world of computing,
which is arguably the reason why this guy is able to do this in the first place
is because he's incredibly powerful computers and the access to them and
changing the way people use the Internet is probably what started this all off
in the first place.
But what he's doing between this and the bullet trains like keys.
He's going to create these magnetic trains that can go across the country in a
fraction of the time it takes to fly.
What kind of plan do you think he flies in?
Something crazy.
Sorry.
Stealth bomber type shit.
Yeah.
Who knows,
man.
He's probably got some ridiculous jet.
Gs Six.
Imagine electric plane.
Madge,
he's been flying electric.
Got To have something that no one knows about.
He's got to have special prototype stuff.
Says phones and computers that we haven't seen yet.
Yeah.
With no chem trails.
It doesn't even make chem trails.
Oh my God.
Kim Trail.
Black helicopters.
All right,
we've got to get the fuck out of here folks.
That's it.
Brian red band.
Thank you sir.
Thank you.
A Red Band on Twitter.
R.
E d.
B.
A.
N not,
there's no d.
Okay.
How dare you.
And a desk,
squad.
Dot TV for all comedy,
um,
dates and upcoming gigs.
Got some.
What do you got going on?
Uh,
me and Tony are just announced that we're bringing killed Tony to Pittsburgh and
Ohio.
We're doing,
she'll Tony.
And then followed by a comedy show.
Oh,
Friday,
November 27th I'll be in Pittsburgh in Ohio.
November 29th
Oh shit.
And desk squad.
Dot TV for all that information.
Yeah.
Um,
and that's it.
I'll be back tomorrow with a,
the iceman.
Wim Hoff.
Oh,
that's right.
Bitches.
You heard it here.
Ooh,
wee one.
One,
one CA.
Okay.
Right.